good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have a
hearing scheduled that we'll be getting
to momentarily and then we have a a
number of bills that we're going to be
meeting in executive session to address
uh but before we do any of that I'd like
Allegiance Pledge of aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible liberty and
all thank you
everyone uh the first bill or the only
Bill we have uh scheduled for public
hearing today is House Bill
1712 and to introduce this I will
recognize the prime sponsor our
representative David Nagel good
morning thank you Mr chairman um
honorary members of the committee um
just to remind you who I am I'm David
Nagel um I
represent belnap district 6 um I'm also
the chairman of the integrative pain
medicine committee formerly called the
HB 66 committee and that's what this
bill is about um we heard this bill last
year um uh and it passed this committee
unanimously the Senate unanimously um
and in front of you is also the report
for the committee the only thing that HB
1712 changes from 66 is the date we're
asking for your permission to continue
our commission for another year um to
remind you what this is about
as you are whereare um there is and was
an opioid crisis and one of the
recommendations Nationwide on dealing
with that was to increase
access uh to or to provide alternative
therapies for pain which sounded like a
really wonderful idea the minor problem
is is we don't provide any access to any
of that so I've been involved in a
nationwide effort for almost 30 years to
try to help solve that problem um and we
have haven't really been able to do it
in a coste effective way I actually
wrote a paper on barriers to resolving
this issue that's five pages long that I
presented at a meeting and and a lot of
them are unnecessary barriers people
guarding Turf things like that and so we
felt that it was really important that
in a statutory way we develop a program
whereby we in provide access to these
therapies and what we call an
integrative way and what that means is
that we're concerned about fragmentation
of care and now where the chiropractor
does this the doctor does that the
massage therapist does that but nobody's
talking to each other and we know that
system doesn't work so and we've known
since 1984 that when those groups of
people work together it does work the
other thing that was important is that
we do this in a New Hampshire way um
people have done this all over the
country the problem is is when we looked
at this it didn't seem their models
worked well and I'm really an advocate
of community-based care which means that
we include all the providers in the
community in ative way and 30 years ago
we had no problems doing that um now we
struggle to do that and I want to we
wanted to find ways to do that um so
that's what the goal of the committee
was was to look at that issue create a
pilot program that we could um show to
New Hampshire the insurers the world
whatever that this can be done in a
coste effective Manner and I will
underline cost effective um we met 10
times um I was really excited with our
group um you know you know you never
know what you're going to get um there
were five of us legislators which I knew
they were going to be there U
representative McKay representative
Merchant um myself um representative
lungren uh Senator chanelly and probably
missing somebody but anyways oh
represented collabro um we met we um
achieved a quorum at every meeting and
that wasn't the best part of this the
best part was the stakeholders who
showed up for every meeting um we had a
very unusual group of people that
actually communicated with each other um
sen uh we had insurers together Patient
Advocates together representatives from
virtually every type of modality and
everybody was really interested in
solving this problem I think the one
group of people that interested me the
most that showed up to every meeting
with the people from hospice and
paliative care who I never
anticipated as this being a need for
them and they actually help guide us to
solve our problem because Hospice in our
country provides a bundled comprehensive
integrative way of managing pain and
symptoms at end of life and what we
discovered was we're really good at
treating people when they're dying we're
not so good at treating them when
they're living and they informed us that
there's two parts to hospice and
paliative care that's the hospice the
paliative care part those the people
that aren't going to die tomorrow they
may live years with their problems and
they found out that they have the same
problems that we have in pain management
in general as they don't have access to
these Services an integrative bundled
way so they showed us the way and we
want to follow it um so that's basically
what we did last year was We we wanted
to research the field see what
everybody's saying we brought in
speakers from all over the country um we
were honored to be added to a Nationwide
Consortium of uh comprehensive
integrative pain providers which
actually we start meeting in a month um
that was step one um and we pretty much
completed that the next step is figuring
out how we're going to make this thing
real and there were five steps to that
number one is where are we going to do
it which we think we've already solved
who's going to do it which we have to
work on how we're going to pay for it
which we're getting steps towards doing
that um how we're going to collect the
data on all this thing and what's our
focus group going to be because I wanted
this to be more broad but it's turning
out that that's not going to be the case
so three of those five things we pretty
much already solved the next phase that
we want to do through next year is
actually to work on those and then the
third thing is obviously to make the
thing real and exist and we pretty much
think we already have two sites to do
that so at this point all I'm asking you
to do is to um support the bill from
last year extend our commission for
another year um and then hopefully by
this time next year um we'll be able to
give you good news that this thing is
actually working and I will tell you the
entire country is watching what we're
doing um because this is a very unique
model so I'm open any questions any
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair uh thank you for taking
questions why are you asking for um an
extension of only one year why not
multiple years and if we ever do see
like you said that this commission is
working will it then be multiple years
um um I that's a great question and um
if I had my way I would have extended it
for three years which probably should
have done we decided to just do it this
way um but I think your idea is a good
idea one thing you'll be interested in
is um one of the things that we realize
there's a big difference between rural
and urban Health you're in a rural
environment last I checked you haven't
had a big city grow up recently right
now so um we felt that we needed two
separate models because they're very
different so there's going to be a rural
and an urban component to what we do and
I thought that was one of the neatest
things that came out of this so far
um representative Wendy Thomas thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um you know this is going to be
asked by me um have you considered um or
are you considering the role of
therapeutic cannabis in pain management
my my I've been doing pain management
now for almost 40 years um in that time
frame I have a very biblical perspective
on this the house of pain is a house
with many rooms and there's place for
everyone in the book that I wrote on
Pain Care policy there is a chapter on
cannabis use and Pain Care um there's
nothing that's going to be
excluded so thank
you uh representative nuten did I see
your hand up a moment ago I'm sorry any
other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you that was
quick um I have no pink cards does
anyone wish to testify on this
bill
that is really quick
okay I I I know U this is like a public
um so if uh no one else wishes to
testify on um HB 1712 I'm going to close
this public hearing and we can't proceed
to the executive session until 10:00
a.m. as noticed uh so uh we're going to
be in recess uh for about about 17
minutes
a
Jerry
Jerry rep of Canon can I call a caucus
you
herey welcome back uh the health and
human services and elderly Affairs we
are now in executive session we have
several bills that we're going to be
taking up during the course of the uh
morning and
afternoon um a couple of our members are
over in commas one of each party so
we're balanced out representatives
kofalt and Merchant will be joining us
later uh but they they are working on
another bill and um uh where it's
balanced out one of each caucus we uh we
it's a mutual agreement uh we are going
to change the order up a little bit
today uh in consideration of um those
members being um you know temporarily
gone um and um so um we're going to be
working on the Bill's notice but we are
going to be changing the order a bit uh
1585 uh we are going to take up at
1M uh so we're going to start with HB
1712 which we just heard from
representative Nagel and I'll repres
I'll recognize representative Nagel for
motions I we have a question um we going
to amend that as outlined to increase
the life of
the uh the thingle
2027 um we don't have the amendment yet
okay have you put the request in yeah I
just wrote something do they think
they're going to be able to get it to us
today I don't know I just sent it like
now should I it's a pretty simple
Amendment I'd suggest we just uh wait
till we get that Amendment and then take
it up when we do hopefully that'll be
today simp am hopefully we get it done
should I call them or um I'll send them
an email to just encourage their speed
if they can thank you okay
so again where it's simple language it's
it's not going to be a big change so all
right so we'll revisit uh 1712 moving on
hb1010 I'll recognize representative
Missour thank you Mr
chair I would like to move hb1010 to
interim study I'll second that motion
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Missour yes uh as we
heard from represent pres ative kushman
um was not here today but she has
requested this be moved to interm study
as we saw at the hearing there was a lot
of interest in this subject and it was
very clear to myself and I know others
that this isn't a very important subject
and more work and research should be
done on it and uh hoping that can be
done in an interim study thank you any
other
discussion representative Shapiro
yes um I would support interim study
because um I feel that I'm in favor of
people having as many options medical
options as they can as long as they're
not hurting other people um even if it's
risky um but I I had a difficulty with
the bill as it was written because it
seems to
take on the one hand the commission on
certified Midwifery seems to have the
ability to um
to govern the both the requirements and
the scope of practice and yet we were
going to bypass them and do it in a you
know in a legislative bill so I think
that um perhaps there's something that
can be done to make the bill better that
wouldn't do that um and encourage more
choice so I would support interim study
okay thank you representative n thank
you Mr chairman um thanks for oh never
mind sor sorry that's called a kneejerk
it's early um I I support interm study
as well I will always have problems with
these shortcut scope of practice bills
um um I think that there's a lot of
issues with this bill I could never
support it at written but I think that
it certainly warrants
discussion okay any other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the CLK
to call the roll motion is uh inm study
on
hb110 representative Lon yes
representative bone yes representative
Bill King yes representative kofalt not
here
representative
leki
yes is that a good pronunciation okay
representative Seth King yes represent
resentative Missour yes representative n
yes representative peloso yes
representative Thomas oh I'm sorry
representative Canon yes representative
Thomas yes representative K yes
representative fedus
yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative
Merchant
Harriet gri
yes representative Palmer
yes representative tez yes and represent
McDonald yes 18 to zero and two not
here okay um I'd move consent okay
there's no objection we'll put that on
the consent
calendar okay next next up is hb6 I'll
do this one so you can make a motion oh
okay uh next up is House Bill 1638 FN
relative to requiring case reviews and
remedial measures for any Department of
Health and Human Services employee who
improperly performs their job do I have
a motion um I move itl is there a
second okay representative and thank you
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you madam chairman um I want
to thank the sponsor of this bill uh for
bringing it Forward uh accountability in
any profession and particularly any kind
of public office is is critically
important uh I particularly have a I
have a particular insight into the
Department of Health and Human Services
I was there for 23 years uh as a an
investigator as a senior investigator
for the Department I did a lot of
internal
investigations uh of
employees I witnessed a lot of um
Personnel actions I'm aware of a lot of
personnel actions and and um as the
department pointed out uh they have a
good handle on holding people
accountable and disciplining them as
necessary uh so while I I I applaud the
intent of the bill I don't think it's
necessary and for that reason I'm moving
itl thank you uh re would you like to
speak to your
motion no is there anybody else who'd
like to
speak being none I'd ask the clerk to
ready
check with the clerk's office it's
better not to hold the G and making a
motion that's fine representative not up
right
good representative L yes representative
bone yes representative Bill King yes
representative
kofol representative licki
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelo
yes representative representative Canon
yes representative thas I'm sorry yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative Nutter upam
yeah representative Shapiro
yes representative
Merchant representative Harriet GTH
yes representative Palmer yes
representative TZ
yes and representative McDonald yes 180
and two not
voting there's no objection we will put
that on
consent oh maybe got something you I'm
sorry and without objection we'll put
that on consent and and then I'll hand
it back over to the chair regular
chairman procedure is
everything okay thank you um
representative Leon I'm moving on next
up is HB 1663 and we'll reverse roles
and I'll recognize representative Leon
for a motion uh thank you Mr chairman
I'd like to move interim study on House
Bill
1663 is there a second second
representative Nagal seconds and would
you like to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you Mr chairman uh this was a
bipartisan chamber bill um that had
sponsorship of both Democrats and
Republicans of both the house and the
Senate there is absolutely important
work to be done with this however it
needs more time and attention than we
can give before the deadline reaches us
um because we had heard such wonderful
testimony and we want to make sure that
we're able to make sure that our Li our
laws are appropriately protective but
not overly burdensome um I would ask the
committee to support an interim study on
this bill so so that we can not lose all
the important testimony that we received
in that hearing and we can get some good
work
done any other discussion representative
Parmer yes I'm I'm glad you that you're
moving for interim study because my
concern was what was going to happen
being a border doctor um the the
difficulty of maybe getting records from
New Hampshire into Vermont where I work
so hopefully that'll be one of the
things that gets worked out thank you
I'll put that in the committee report as
well as one of the necessary
discussion thing none okay I'll ask the
clerk to call the all motion is interim
study on hb1 1663 FM representative Lon
yes representative bone yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Jim
kofo representative liii yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
peloso
yes representative Canon
yes representative Thomas yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative nut upam yes
representative
Shapiro yes
Merchant not here representative Harriet
gri
yes representative Palmer yes
representative tez
McDonald I'm sorry uh
yes 18 Zer and to not voting there's no
objection we will put that on
consent um
one bill that uh we uh also had noticed
for today is hb300 we had we've decided
to continue that until March 20th but I
understand there might be some
discussion on that uh representative Lon
yes and thank you for that purpose um
I'll move in interum study just so that
we can officially be able to discuss
this bill for a few minutes um just as
our colleagues are over in Commerce and
we can sort of address the approach that
I'd like to take on the bill if there's
anybody who'd be willing to second that
representative baz of
seconds thank you thank you Mr speak is
your intention just for the purposes of
discussion but not an actual vote
correct um because in executive session
we can't just sit and talk on a bill
unless there's a motion on the on the
table so I will be withdrawing that
afterwards um I think that this bill is
very important especially because New
Hampshire's right to try law was passed
before there was Federal legislation to
allow it um there are conflicts between
the two and there would be new new
conflicts created with the language of
the bill and those conflicts between
what we would ask of companies to
provide their Therapeutics and what
they're required to do by the federal
government to be able to continue
selling those Therapeutics around uh or
continue developing those Therapeutics
when they're in Conflict that's going to
limit any access that we have in the
state um so we have both the
investigational drugs that um are
allowed under compassionate use and
there's other programs as well um I
believe that it's absolutely critical to
make sure that if a um company's not
able to open up a clinical trial site
for a patient who um where it would be
willing where there would be appropriate
compassionate use for that drug that we
provide a pathway so that the long and
rigorous process of opening a single
patient um clinical trial site is not
required in allow order to allow
patients to have this access um it's I
believe that it's also quite important
important that we point this language to
the bill that was passed last term about
informed about um off Lael drug use
because of a drug is already already
approved for a use but a physician is
concerned about that use off label in a
terminal patient we must make sure that
this a language would Point them to that
because as long as there is informed
consent documented um the medical boards
will not are prohibited from taking
action simply based upon the off label
status of that drug um I do think that
it is important and I'll be speaking
with uh the medical board just to
understand if there's anything else that
would need to be done um prob most
likely um I would look to have the
language to have the medical board um
draft any rules necessary in order to
provide appropriate safety and
protection for both the doctor and the
patient while maximizing availability to
any Therapeutics um that would would
offer a chance at life extension or
potentially cure for any of these
patients um so I think it's an
absolutely critical bill um I I'm just
worried that the reason why it wasn't
working so well with our existing law is
because of the conflicts and I think
that this um would create some
additional conflicts so I this is one of
those ones that now that a couple other
things are done I can sort of stick my
nose to the grindstone and the next week
or so I'll make sure that it remains
gerine um so that we don't run into that
issue and um hopefully be able to do
something because is you know the last
thing we want to do is have bureaucrats
and red tape get in the way of a patient
and Doctor Who want to try and extend or
save somebody's life is
Shapiro yes thank you um thank you Mr
chair and
um I don't know if this is a question or
statement but th this bill is really
important I think and I think once again
people should have um
as much Choice as possible as long as
it's not doesn't endanger somebody else
um I didn't really understand why the
requirements for consent seemed to be
um seem to be increased in this bill um
and in you know in my cursory reading
made it more honorous to consent um I
think there had to be two people and um
it had to be um notorized I think um so
I I hope that'll be looked into too
because I don't know why the consent
should be more honorous for this than
for other
things um I would tend to agree uh we
actually have the prime sponsor of the
bill filling in with us today so I don't
know if it would be appropriate to uh
see if he can give us any insight on uh
why he he made it a little more onerous
on the informed on the consent side
representative liwicki thank you Mr
chairman uh the reason for doing that is
that when people are in a hospital
environment uh they are subject to
coercion and medical people uh typically
we get group think from the uh medical
personnel I'm certainly willing to
revise it in some way but I think it's
very important that uh the witnesses uh
the to the informed consent yet the
informed consent truly be voluntary
rather than subject to uh medical
personnel knowing what's right and not
allowing a patient to do what the
wants
any other discussion representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman um I think that
actually I'm wondering if that might be
something that we can tease out where
when the patient is requesting access to
it we keep the same streamlined but if
the provider chooses to offer something
that's like this that then then um maybe
we have the the the Board of Medicine or
somebody else give us some rules around
how to appropriately ensure that there
is consent when you are bringing
somebody in um when you're offering
something that's not current currently
available would pursuing that path
resolve those concerns for
you thank you other discussion
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I just have a question uh regarding
the the bill so I'm going to ask you um
when my mom was in hospice once she got
on um Perpetual morphine she they they
said she could no longer make any legal
decisions and so my brother had to step
in as the authority would that is that a
all I'm not really sure it's not
something that I had considered um I
think that you know having a family
member be um a witness to the informed
consent would certainly be appropriate
um and you know whether a patient you
know obviously if a patient is
effectively stoned they can't truly uh
give informed consent well a family
member could certainly assist I know
I've been through a similar situation
with my sister
and who did not have any kind of durable
power of attorney and for 5 years it was
a
mess other discussion representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman um so there's a
little known law that we passed uh three
years ago that allows for surrogacy
where if there's not an somebody who's
assigned um that they're able to go
through a chain of command the question
would be if um if if you would feel
comfortable handing over that
responsibility fully to somebody who's
who is um clearly somebody who's been
named by the person should be able to
make those decisions the question my
question would be if somebody who's a
surrogate so not officially named but
basically a a descending order of next
of kin would do that or if that perhaps
at that point at that point the person
is probably so close to it maybe we
shouldn't be experimenting or trying to
play God I'm just curious what your
Insight would be
there I think we could discuss this
offline one of the situations you know
and this is subjective with my sister
was that she would get offer medications
and she would be incapable of making
decisions when the she got back on the
medications she did resume um being able
to work it and I I just think I'm not
sure we can hash this out right now
right
discussion saying none uh Mr chairman
may I withdraw my motion for inter study
please you may and learn to okay so um
at this point we've had the motion
withdrawn on 1300 we'll continue it to
thir uh to March
20th and
um we can probably do this I can okay
next up we would will'll take up HB 1568
FN representative lons um thank you Mr
chairman I'd move interm study on House
Bill 1568 relative to Medicaid
reimbursement for non-transport eery
mergency Medical Services Bill calls
okay is there a second representative
palazov representative palazov seconds
representative Leon do you wish to speak
to your motion um yes thank you Mr
chairman uh this is a complicated and
complex bill that I'm not sure if should
really have come to Health and Human
Services but probably should have gone
to Commerce because I heard quite a few
discussions about M about um the sorted
billing in that committee um if the
discussion can help clarify things for
me here then I may be interested in
another motion but right now I truly
don't understand exactly where those
costs are going to go exactly who's
going to be liable um how this would I
recognize that there could be some
benefit to those people the the towns
and other ambulance services but there's
going to be an offsetting cost as well
and I I truly don't have enough
information to pass the bill as it
stands but I think that it's too
valuable to kill so that's why I've made
the motion of interim
study other
Shapero yes um I I will vote against
interim study I think this is a um I I I
think I agree with the representative
that it probably should have come to
Commerce instead of to our committee um
but I think that um we did get a fair
amount of explanation and um the intent
of this bill is to have Medicaid
reimbursement for when um Emergency
Services goes out to a to a home or to
anywhere and um provide services um but
doesn't need to take
somebody transport someone to a hospital
and right now um emergency services are
eating those costs we know know there's
a an issue with um emergency services in
the state um keeping them um robust and
keeping them functioning and so I think
that we should be doing what we can to
support their functioning um by having
Medicaid reimbursement which will not be
enough of course um because Medicaid
reimbursement is low um but it will be
doing something towards um ensuring the
um medical infrastructure for our state
so I would vote I would vote against
interim study I would urge people to
vote against interim study so that we
could um pass this along and maybe it
would go to um Commerce in the
Senate is that
possible anything's possible it's up to
the Senate President okay anyway that is
that is
my thoughts okay representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman I there's another
Committee involved in this and that's
Finance I mean there's a no not at all
really no it's too late it uh it's not a
second committee Bill W a second
committee bills were weeks ago because
this is an expensive Bill
potentially
wow other discussion representative ATZ
yes thank you I um appreciate the
comments I I think it's really expensive
or it will be even more expensive if our
emergency service providers go out of
business which I think is a concern that
was raised I'm also very impressed by
the showing that we have that I'm
assuming is related to this interest
given the uh insignias that I see on
people's clothes um because I can't tell
who all the lobbyists are so I I I heard
loud and clearly that there's a real ask
for this and it it makes sense that you
know we don't have to figure out the
details of how to make it happen we just
have to provide the the guidance that it
needs to get figured out and I would be
also in favor of uh trying to make sure
we pass this and will vote against in
term
study other discussion representative
Palmer yes I'm I'm also against interim
study um increasingly we have I've ended
up taking care of patients in our small
critical access hospital that needed to
be in a tertiary Care Center be for
longer than I would like because we
could just not get
transport and so anything that
will improve the ability of of um am
ambulance services to provide service
and staff appropriately I I think we
need to move in that direction and I
think the other thing is it's from a
another point of view it's really not
fair for an ambulance service to go out
to somebody's house pick them up put
them in back in bed and then drive back
and not get paid anything for that
so thank you a representative n um I
also agree that those kinds of services
should be covered as I've hit an age
group where more and more of my family
members are needing quick assistance but
not admission into a hospital so and of
course in nashwa it's only a couple
miles to get there from an ambulance so
I'm in favor of um not interm study but
ought to pass and let others work out
the details representative chapero thank
you Mr chairman um I understand that um
representative Leon's
um idea of sending this inter term study
is not because she thinks it's a bad
idea but just because it that the
financial aspect of it has not been
fully examined and this is really a
question of the chair or anybody else
who might know can if we if we pass this
and put in our report that we think it
should go to finance in the Senate might
that have an influence and might um they
be be able to examine the financial um
dimensions and then it would come back
to the house
obviously um that's a possibility but
there's no way of knowing what as we
know our the other body is a pretty
independent group of people so I
wouldn't want to try to say well we can
we can suggest we can suggest
yes other discussion representative Lon
uh thank you Mr chairman I think that
this discussion has made both made me
realize the importance and also the
magnitude of this um recognizing that
there's probably people who aren't
calling for this now because they've had
somebody who's fallen and that they need
the assistance to get up I think that
it's very important but also if we're
under reimbursing through Medicaid we
may actually be causing more of a
problem too for these providers this is
not a good situation to be in and
I my concern is just that there's so
much that Still Remains unknown on this
this um there's so many bills this year
that it's hard to count on the Senate to
do the hard work that um that we haven't
been able to figure out as well um so
this is that's just my my large concern
here representative Nagel um question
and a comment and a question I it
surprised me that this wasn't reimbursed
now that really surprised me but um um
having seen a lot of visits that there's
no transport involved but um my other
question is if this goes to interim
study it still stays in our committee
correct it doesn't go to finance at that
point am I correct uh that would be
correct but I know that we have had um
with interim Studies have people come in
not officially but have people from
other committees that can come and
discuss and help us better understand
what the implications are especially
because some of these would probably
then um because it would be drafting
another bill we'd probably want to look
at the expertise of people who could do
that so that we could introduce
something and perhaps uh have the
correct sponsors on that one so that it
might go to the right committee um I
know that this year has just been so
difficult with with everything we're
doing the best we can all around um but
I I I just think that passing it and
hoping that somebody else would do the
work for us is is not the right way to
business
okay m dire as always has been very
helpful apparently Commerce does not
deal with Medicaid at all so that's
that's um uh which uh which I guess in
retrospect makes sense uh but she's
offered to do some research on this and
and enable us to make a a better
judgment if we want to continue this to
March 20th or we would have to withdraw
that motion um I'd be willing to
withdraw that motion I think that it's
important I just we just need to make
sure that we can understand what we're
actually doing with so I'd be willing to
withdraw representative
Shapiro I I wonder if part of the
research that could be done would to be
to get some kind of financial um note
about the implications of of passing
this so um we could at least have an
idea of what we're working with
representative
TZ I want can we ask Mr Williams if
there's any information he could share
Williams okay thank you uh Christino is
that something is is any of the
financial stuff anything that you might
be able to check out for us
or okay thank you representative TZ yeah
thank I have one additional comment I
mean
this is a public good that we don't
think about until we need it so I kind
of feel like it doesn't really matter
what the finances are it's a need New
Hampshire's a rural State we have all
these critical access hospitals that
have closed we're hearing that uh uh
emergency providers show up provide care
that is needed and if patients are lucky
enough to not have to be transported
that's great um but if if that's ending
up being a sort of a stop Gap care
provision that people need um I I don't
understand why we're even debating it
like it needs to get figured out we're
not going to figure it out no matter
what the bill is uh it's it's a this is
a policy decision do we believe that
this is something that should be
supported because we've heard over and
over that that this is causing them
Financial Risk and you know when it's
your mother that needs the ambulance
you're going to be pretty upset if
there's no one there to show
up other
discussions represent L and
you I just wanted to just scan through
the bill text again real
quick uh so looking at the bill text
again it's not Medicare it's just
Medicaid so we do have some elderly
citizens who are on both but Medicaid is
more on um on on a younger time um time
because we have the people who are on
Medicaid obviously there is overlap um
and obviously we do have quite a few
people who perhaps do have needs to be
able to do some of this as well but this
is just Medicaid it's not Medicare so a
lot of our elderly family members are on
the Medicare as opposed to the Medicaid
and that's a federal issue so this is a
smaller wedge um it does look like um
there was a a fiscal note that has been
shown but it says that it's over a
million dollars General over a million
Federal and they don't know how much it
will be
um so because there's just a lot of
uncertainty I so so I had uh moved to
withdraw my motion of interim study so
we can get some more information ahead
of our our 20 our meeting on March 20th
yes I'm withd drawing my second okay so
we will continue 156 at FN to March
20th uh just just for everyone's uh
awareness we're not planning to meet
next week so we'll be dealing with any
bills after today uh on March 20th which
is the final day we can deal with them
all right
um
okay again we're you know to accommodate
uh the two members of the committee who
um who are trying to help out on an
important issue in Commerce we're trying
to uh you know jocky around a little bit
here uh representative Shapiro uh did
you want to talk about 1028 this
time
yes and everybody should have an
amendment uh 09 63h that representative
Shapiro distributed
earlier
so would you like to move move the yes I
will move that we adopt amendment 0963
to House Bill
1028 is there a
second representative Nagel seconds
representative Shapiro would you like to
speak to your motion yes so this is a
bill that was brought forth
um I don't remember the sponsor but it
was obviously brought forth on the on
the
um by advocates for the developmental
disabilities Community who felt that the
statute that was currently in place
including the um definition of mental
illness um which I think is you know
beyond this bill is a very flawed
definition but um that the definition um
um intellectual ual
disabilities
um that the me that the definition of
mental illnesses did not include people
with
intellectually intellectual disabilities
if it was primarily caused by
developmental disabilities and so um
whatever the wording is seems to be that
the reality is is that sometimes um
people with intellectual disabilities or
developmental disabilities are sometimes
denied um Mental Health Care by the
state system by New Hampshire hospital
by the mental health centers um because
they are simply told that this is
um this is a a developmental issue not a
mental illness issue and so this is an
attempt um the bill in itself is an
attempt to U make it so that people with
co-occurring disorders um whe whether
they have um an intellectual disability
or not if they have a mental illness
that they will be eligible for treatment
through the state system of mental
bill
the the initial bill did two things um
on line 18 and 19 and 20 it said an
individual shall not be determined
ineligible for services under this
chapter on the basis of co-occurrence of
mental illness and an intellectual
developmental disability and the
amendment that um that we're bringing
today um leaves that in um the initial
bill also takes out um
in Roman numeral
10 um Part B it removes intellectual
disability and in working with
representative Nagel um we both felt
that that did not make sense because um
it was initially put in there because
you wanted to be able to discern the
difference between someone who had an
intellectual disability and mental
illness we didn't want people to assume
that everyone who had a disability was
also mental mentally ill so I think it
was initially put in there as a
protection for people and it didn't make
sense for us to take it out however
people um Disability Advocates felt like
this was often used um to um create an
obstacle to people being getting mental
health care so my
Amendment
um changes on line eight in the
amendment it's says instead of primarily
caused by epilepsy intellectual
disability um intoxication Etc it
says it does not include impairment
solely caused and we think that that is
a a small change but one that
clarifies um that we're talking about
um we're talking about cooccurring
disorders and we're saying that people
should be eligible for mental health
care um unless their the behavior or um
symptoms shown are solely um a solely
caused by um that disability so it's a
small change
um I think it satisfies some of the
people who brought the bill in the first
place um I think it clarifies things and
um I would urge you to adopt the
Amendment representative Nal you want to
speak to you make motion also sure um I
I this was a lesson in legislation for
me I've never been involved in so much
discussion based on the strike out of a
single word but it was it was it was it
was really important and impressive and
I have to say just viscerally just
seeing that strikeout from the minute I
saw it really bothered me a lot part of
it is because I have a son with an
intellectual disability I have a cousin
with an intellectual disability my wife
would say she has a husband with an
intellectual disability but anyway so um
she'll have
to you know I I think the reason why
that's excluded because historically
people looked at intellectual disability
and mental illness as the same thing and
I think it was important that that be
excluded um I've dealt with people with
disabilities my entire life and um my
one of my papers that I I wrote back in
the 1990s was on full stroke depression
and we were looking at the neural
physiology of that is this a separate
thing or reactive thing is it from the
the neurophysiology the stroke itself
whatever but we always looked at them as
two separate things that we treat the
stroke here we do not deny your right to
have full treatment of your depression
is a separate thing and so to me they it
was important that we acknowledge the
comorbidity but that they're not the
same thing and it seemed to me when you
did that strike out you're removing it
that distinction with that said it
seemed seemed to me that everything that
they wanted to accomplish with this bill
was in the SEC the last paragraph and I
thought that was really important and I
just want to make one public statement
it really bothered me that this bill is
even necessary um um um I I I don't
understand how you could deny people
access to care for depression and
disability is so common or other things
that they really deserve their they're
worthy of their own distinction and and
they need to be addressed as such so I
representative chapero yes I just in
case I wasn't clear enough the initial
bill struck out intellectual disability
the the amendment puts it back in but
says solely caused by it and I I do want
to make one comment there was a lot of
very compelling
testimony unfortunately I think that
even with this bill um it may it may
reduce one obstacle um um but certainly
people with intellectual disabilities or
developmental disabilities aren't the
only people waiting on long list to get
Services um we know that the emergency
room boarding problem is a problem maybe
it's more of a problem for people with
developmental disabilities but it's it's
a problem for children it's a problem
for adults and um I don't s this is one
thing that we can do to to maybe ease
the situation for some people but I
don't think we should fool ourselves
into thinking it's going to solve the
whole
problem representative Lon um thank you
Mr chairman um I think that this is a
really interesting and potentially good
way to go um it's something that I
probably would want to just sort of um
have a couple minutes to think about um
I I'm thinking it looks like we may be
getting our friends back from uh when we
l from Commerce um and I know that we've
been trying to manage what we're doing
with all of that too um so I didn't know
if it' be possible for us maybe to have
um have a caucus just to be able to
discuss it and just figure out time
frame wise as well because I think that
this um probably is an important one to
make sure that everybody can be on the
same page about because this definition
of mental illness is pretty significant
um so either if we did it that way or if
we withdrew it and got back to 1712
because I've heard back from LS that we
can't actually change that date because
it's in chapter law not in statutes um
so I didn't know it would make sense to
withdraw that maybe go through 1712 and
then take a break in which we could
caucus and then everybody could expect
how much time they could have to use the
facilities and whatnot um before we're
there although then again we have
everybody back too so I'm not sure what
the best way to go forward is I've just
been trying to trying to work on the Fly
here together today and uh and
accommodate everything but I would like
to get have a chance to sort of wrap my
head around this change from primarily
to
solely okay well we can um as I
understand it even though it's on the
floor we could I think we can continue
it till we don't need to withdraw it
where we're going to continue it today I
don't
believe I don't believe um I I'm not
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure exactly
what the rest process I don't know if
maybe we just want to take um take a
caucus until 5 or 10 after just to give
people a chance to use the restroom and
whatnot and discuss it a little bit and
we also were trying to make sure that we
had time to get you guys back in because
we've done just about as much business
as we could without you thank you thank
you all right so okay why don't we do
that then why don't we recess uh for
what are you proposing 20 minutes uh
yeah um probably until um 11:10 by 20
minutes 22 minutes right we'll take a
relatively brief recess we'll
Republicans will be be having a caucus
in the committee office and um anyone
else who needs to take care of anything
in the meantime please feel free to do
minutes
okay I'd like to reopen the executive
session and we were discussing uh HB
1028 before we uh
recessed uh so I'd like to return to
that a motion is on the floor I believe
for
Amendment um
discussion I'm seeing
none the cler is ready I'll ask him to
rooll we're on Bill 1028 Mr chair AHB
1028 as an amendment you should have a
copy of
0963 authored by representative Shapiro
thank you and U ghost authored
co-authored by representative
okay okay uh Mr Clark representative
land yes representative bone yeah
representative Bill King yes
representative copal yes representative
lki
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nel yes representative
Palo
yes representative Canon
yes representative Thomas yes represent
M
yes represent fedus
yes representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Harriet G
yes represent Palmer
yes represent TZ yes and represent
McDonald yes 20 to zero to
zero okay do I have a motion uh on HVB
1028 as the am motion representative
chapero yes I
move um ought to pass on House Bill
by
0963 he representative McKay
seconds any discussion on the rain
motion of ought to pass as amended for
HB
writing representative Lon yes
representative bone yes representative
Bill King yes representative cofal
yes representative Lui
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative peloso yes
representative Canon yes representative
Thomas yes representative K yes
representative fedus
yes representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative area gther
yes representative Palmer yes
representative TZ yes and repres pres
McDonald yes 20 to
zero there's no objection we will put
calendar okay now uh let's revisit uh HB
1712 representative Lon you said that
you cannot get an amendment on that is
that correct um yes correct because this
is not a statutory study committee we
can extend it past November of the um
year I knew there was a good reason
okay with that uh representative Nagel
do you want to make a motion I'll make a
motion ought to pass on HB 1712 and I
will second that motion Representative
notam no you will okay that's fine
that's even better rep representative
Nagel do you want to speak to your
motion okay okay uh any discussion on
the
motion seeing none a motion is out to
pass on HB 1712 when the clerk is
writing representative Lon yes represent
bone yes representative Bill King yes
represent kopal yes representative luii
yes representive Seth King yes
representive Missour yes representive
Nagel yes represent peloso yes represent
Canon yes represent Thomas yes represent
McKay yes represent fedus
yes represent nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Harriet G yes
representative Palmer yes representative
tez yes and represent McDonald
yes 208 to zero okay there is no
objection we will put that on the
consent
calendar next up is HB 1280
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman I move a to pass on House Bill
1280 is there a
second I can SEC well I represented
Missour seconds representative L do you
wish to speak to your motion um yes
thank you Mr chairman uh I this is a
bill which would take basically the um
informed consent guidelines that are
already in the AMA requirements and put
it in statute one of the areas that we
have challenges around is
enforceability um whether that's whether
that's swearing somebody in to testify
when there's no enforceability if you're
not a if if you can't do anything if
nobody tells you if somebody tells you
something that's not the truth whether
it is any of other statutes that may or
may not be followed but it's one thing
when you have if by putting this into
the law there would be another reason to
make sure that any of the providers who
aren't following through on informed
consent are actually doing this uh this
is one of those important areas where
there is a distinction between in
provider-based informed consent and
patient based informed consent and this
makes sure that the patients have to be
part of the discussion um that's been a
bit of a gray area in New Hampshire
where some people say that it's only
based off of what a doctor wants you to
know but that leaves a lot of liability
for our for our providers if we get this
into statute and they're clearly
following not only AMA guidelines for
Physicians but also it's in the state
law that provides a lot of protection
for them if somebody says that the
correct informed consent was not
followed because it just provides more
clarity by putting there I know some
people would want to expand this to
other provider types as well and I
recognize that but you can't really just
take the AMA guidelines for Physicians
and then give that to everybody else
that would need to take a a little bit
more nuanced look and that's something
that I know I personally am interested
in doing over time because informed
consent is vital you can't have a
patient patient be an active participant
in their healthare and their recovery if
they truly don't know what they're doing
and why um and so I'd like to continue
moving towards this uh more outlined
more collaborative process so that we
can make sure that providers and
patients are working together to improve
health other
discussion representative Nagel thank
you Mr chairman I appreciate everything
that you've done on this bill and all
the discussions that it's led to and I
we're too very different hats on this
bill um the one hat is a Doctor Who's
got way too many people in my exam room
right now telling me what to do when I
don't even know who I'm treating anymore
which is kind of really sad statement
and it just seems to me that this is yet
another intrusion on on that
relationship and and especially
considering everything in this bill
already exists I already have to do all
this I have to take a class every year
that reinforces I got to do all this at
the same point um we are witnessing a
corporate takeover Health Care before
our very eyes and I'm not sure that this
is so much directed as me the doctor and
my patient as I am at the corporate
provider so the one side of me is really
violently opposed to this bill the other
side of me is violently in supportive of
this bill which means that I guess I'm
schizophrenic so um I I I'm probably
going to not support it but I really
appreciate it and what I really like
what you said um representative was I
think this does need to lead to a lot
broader discussion on a lot of levels
appreciate other discussion
representative
Merchant thank you Mr
chair I'm of the mindset I think also
with representative Nagel the intent of
the spill I trly truly support um I
think I'm really concerned about how
it's going to impact the medical
community and also the care for patients
we have Physicians that are today buried
in paperwork
and my concern is that we're adding
another layer of paperwork to it so I
don't know what impact this is going to
have on the ability of the provider to
have enough time to see the patient
versus take care of all the paperwork so
I'd rather go to interim study and talk
about this I think it has a lot of
merits but I'd like to be sure what what
we're doing actually has been thought
through and we hear from the medical
community how this may impact them so
that's kind of where I'm coming down but
I do want to say thank you to the
representative for bringing to our
attention representative Mel yeah I just
wanted to clarify what you just said I
don't really think it's going to add to
the paperwork at all I I I mean when I
started out you you had talked about
patient centered informed consents
that's what I created I've written at
least 30 of them and now I'm told I'm
not allowed to do that that the risk
management people have to rate the
informed consent for me and so when I re
it was funny after we had our hearing on
this I went and looked at the informed
consent patients were signning in the O
before I'm about to do a procedure and
it was a patient i' had known for a long
time and I looked at her and I said did
you read this and she goes no and I go
you know what neither have I let's read
it together when we read it I go I'm not
signing this are you and she goes no and
I I it really actually led to a big
discussion of trying to take this back
from the risk management people to do
exactly what you just said so that's why
this is really important but as far as
paperwork it is so easy now I just sign
they sign nobody even looks at it and I
think that's really tragic
other discussion representative
Palmer so I think that the concern I
have is um a lot of what Dr Nagel and
and I mean representative Nagel and
representative Merchant said um which is
it's clearly a very important issue um
but for example in um so on on line 15
where it says that it says the
Physicians shall include information
about the burdens risks and expected
benefit it's of all options including
foregoing treatment and um the so I am
concerned that well who's
deciding that and and how do I document
that every time I make a decision about
a patient uh so for example I mean I
might be just simply choosing an an
antibiotic for a patient but now do I
have to document exactly why I picked
that one I mean usually there is some
indication of why because it's the
correct one for that diagnosis but I
I again I guess what I'm saying is I
would support what representative merch
said which would be interim study to
make sure that we're not creating a
monster that's going to make you know my
life and everybody else is really
difficult at a time when we can't
recruit anybody I I mean I'm hoping to
retire at the end of this year but I'm
probably not going to be able to and one
of the one of the reasons is the
paperwork burden and I don't want to
increase it I want to make sure that
this
you know if this could be done in a way
where we're streamlining things so that
it's you know it's really clear exactly
what needs to be there that would be
great but I'm not right now I'm
uncomfortable representative
Merchant thank you for that pres
Palmer as an option to interim study
this is not an early Bill correct it is
not so if rep and lon's willing to sit
down with myself and some other folks
and Hammer out something that's more
logical that based fund medical
community and so forth I think that may
be another way to get to the same thing
without holding it up complet of this
legislative cycle representative L on
that would work for me we do still have
another two weeks um I I I think that
just we've worked well together sort of
offline I don't think we need a
subcommittee so we can just sort of
discuss this we can but i' encourage us
to have both represent Nel and
representative Palmer part of that
conversation because they come from the
medical community more than I do I think
the uh input from them would be truly
valuable
representative Nel I'm sorry that
representative kushman's not here to
answer this but my understanding and I I
did look through the AMA guide this is
directly from the AMA guides there's
nothing in here that we're not supposed
to already be doing um I mean the way I
do it maybe I should tell everybody else
how to do this but I create an informed
consent that's part of my entire process
so when I meet with the person tell them
what I want to do what I don't want to
do that inform what I created was part
of that whole discussion
so when it comes time to sign it they
already know what they're signing
because we already talked about it um I
I don't think that that happens but this
is what I'm already supposed to do
there's nothing new here um and and and
40 years ago my dad informed me the most
common reason doctors are suit is
failure to get informed consent and um
so 40 years ago he taught me to do
everything that's in this bill and
that's why I struggle with voting
against it um but it's what I have
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair as I listen to what you're saying
representa Nel if it's already in the
AMA guidelines the challenge with
guidelines are exactly that they're
guidelines not statute or requirement so
maybe by simply making this bill saying
that the positions to follow ma ma mama
guidelines will be sufficient because at
that point in time it then requires them
to follow the guidelines versus putting
actually in statute I just throwing it
out there representative
profile uh thank you Mr chairman so I I
I have concerns about that approach I
have concerns whenever we put something
in statute that references an external
organization whose standards could very
well change um we we are then in essence
delegating legislative authority to an
organization that is not only Not
Elected uh by citizens of New Hampshire
they may not even be from New Hampshire
at all so I I would just I would um urge
caution in taking that approach
representative Nagel did I see your hand
up I guess so yeah I I just wanted to
say that what representative Merchant
said is already in rules um it's not in
statute but it is in rules yeah my
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for all this
conversation and this Insight um I think
that the difference between having the
need to follow AMA guidelines and rules
that allows the medical board to look
and see well actually what you're doing
is consistent with where the ma AMA is
headed when I was a device analyst we
had the guidelines from all the
different medical societies and you know
it's sort of the Baseline to be able to
have those guidelines but sometimes
something that was emerging in somebody
that you were doing actually ended up
contradicting the guidelines because
there was emerging evidence but it yet
wasn't yet the fully adopted practice um
and so that's why I think the idea of
sort of airlifting one of these areas
that is so crucial to this care specific
spefically out of a guideline that's
already been vetted and sort of freeze
that in time and freeze that in statute
and have it so that it's a shell instead
of a May um I think makes sense in areas
like this especially ones where where
you see that it should be such General
such General um action something that we
should be doing um if if we're not able
to get to an agreement on a to pass
today I'd be happy to pull that back
withdraw that and see what we can get to
for the 20th so that perhaps we can come
out
have more of our bills on the consent
calendar as opposed to needing to debate
them on the floor if uh with by spending
a little bit more time we could get
there so with that I'll withdraw my
motion okay representative Missour did
you second
that okay are you withdrawing in a
second okay that's just a
question all right so the motion has
been withdrawn and we will continue that
along with 1568 to March 20th
okay um Mr chairman for May yes
represent Merchant this will be not an
official subcommittee this will be an ad
hoc committee so we can via we can
communicate via Zoom informal effort by
informal effort right so we can utilize
the
technology versus meeting a person
correct sure representative
representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman I'm not
sure I understand this but I hope that
when there's further discussions um that
the issue of
um on page one line 24 where it talks
about patients rights is that an
addition to the patients rights that
already exist is it completely different
patients rights and does it make sense
to have patients rights in more than one
place so I'm not really asking for
anything right now but I'm just hoping
that that'll be part of the discussion
uh that's actually a really important
point the patients Bill of Rights is not
binding on provider it's binding on
facilities so it wouldn't be appropriate
to have this in the patients Bill of
Rights because that that's about the
facilities not the provider themselves
maybe it shouldn't be called patients
rights maybe it should be if if you can
I'd be happy to consider other words
that you have but the right to have
informed consent I think is pretty
fundamental but I'd be happy to discuss
that offline as our legislative friends
in our adhoc type way okay thank you
I'll think about it thank you
any other discussion on HB
1280 all right moving on uh next up is
HB 1347 representative cofal do you want
to make a motion uh yes I move interim
study on House Bill 1347 okay I'll
second that uh would you like to speak
to your motion um sure so I I think that
this bill by the sponsor's own admission
was not ready for prime time it doesn't
actually um ptain or it wasn't intended
to pertain to the refugee resettlement
program um there are things uh yeah it's
just it was not um it was not drafted to
align with his
intent having said that I think we have
all heard concerns about um veterans who
are being displaced from Services people
who are um who are not necessarily
getting the services they need not in
New Hampshire uh but we've heard stories
from other states so I think that there
is a legitimate question that needs to
be uh discussed and investigated and so
for that reason I would move inm study
thank you other
discussions
see I was just gonna say that sounds
very reasonable and I'll vote in favor
of that okay representative
Shapero
um I agree that this would this would be
an a an acceptable outcome but I'm going
to vote against it in hopes that um it
can be ited I think that um as was said
by the previous speaker the um the the
sponsor themselves said that the bill
was poorly written and didn't align with
his intent um and I would support
interim study if the if the intent that
was talked about was really a broad
discussion about immigration and how
immigration affects New Hampshire both
the incredible benefits it brings and
the problems that it brings and how we
um you know immigration work for New
Hampshire um I I just read in in a
business magazine this morning before I
came that um while the population of New
Hampshire is increasing um that that the
population
increase from 2010 to current half of
that population increase um is from
International International immigration
and um I
think so unfortunately to me because I
would like to defer to representative
Edwards the prime sponsor unfortunately
to me all the conversation after it was
acknowledged that the bill was not as a
should be was about how to um make sure
that immigrants don't cut in line and
um I don't first of all I don't think
that happens in New Hampshire second of
all I think there are federal laws about
um for example for Medicaid about um
whether people in certain categories of
um non-citizen status have to be given
Medicaid or have to be elig not have to
be given have to be eligible so I think
the discussion after the acknowledgment
that this was not a well-written bill
was all leading to um a future bill that
would be divisive in my in my mind and
so um I would rather vote for itl but I
understand if people would vote for um
interim study um and the discussion will
be what it is if that happens
thank you other
discussion seeing none okay the motion
is interim study on hb1
1347 I'll ask clerk to call the
role representative L yes representative
B yes representative Bill King yes
representative cofal yes representative
liwi yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelov
no represent McKay
yes
representative Shapiro
no representative Merchant
yes representative Harriet gathri
no representative Palmer
yes Representative tez
yes 13 to
7 okay um representative sh or someone
is there going to be a Minority Report
you uh represent Shir are you writing
that one or Minority Report
you
okay uh next up is hp67
representative Seth King I know you have
an
amendment thank you Mr chair yes I've
handed out the amendment everybody
should have a copy of it um I'd like to
move that we adopt uh Amendment 2024
d05 91h ought to
pass okay is there a
second second motions been made by uh
representative Seth King and seconded by
representative mer Merchant
representative king would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank
you this is a very
interesting um part of the bill um that
we're going to be discussing here um and
I just want to preface it by saying that
I think honest people can disagree on
this issue and I totally understand
where the people who disagree with me on
this are coming from and I don't blame
them one bit um however that being said
I'd like to still
the position I'm making um and um so to
start off there this bill I really see
it as as two parts um there is the first
part which allows for baby boxes and
also increasing the number of days that
an individual can drop off a baby at a
baby box for example from seven to uh 61
days I believe the second part of the
bill is in add added exclusionary clause
um that I I think is just a bridge too
far for me personally there is already
um immunity in the current statute that
allows for parents to drop off their
baby and not have to fear prosecution
for neglect in that in that way of
dropping off the baby um but what this
exclusionary clause would do is that if
a parent for example were to drop off a
baby that had been severely
intentionally abused in ways that we can
use our imagination but I'm not going to
say
here the evidence that the state would
have of that abuse would be on that
child and it's likely that there would
be no other
way for law enforcement to get other
evidence of the abuse so so that the the
abuse is the evidence is strictly on
that child and this exclusionary clause
would tie the hands of law enforcement
from being able
to prosecute or at least use the
evidence found on the child in a
prosecutor prosecutorial
manner um
and I know people don't always like
analogies as much as I do but I love
analogy so I'm going to use an analogy
here just to sort of I think wrap help
wrap our heads around what we're
actually doing um I think many of us
have heard of the uh the moral conundrum
if you are a conductor on a train and
you're going down the track and you
can't stop and you see five people tied
to the track um but you have the option
of you know cranking the you know
cranking the levers and switching to a
track that only has three people tied to
it which do you
choose um and that might be easy if all
else is being equal um but but what
happens if the five people are really
elderly and the three people are babies
or what if the five people are convicted
convicts and the three are uh known
Heroes to the community and you could
keep playing these games the point is is
it's a very difficult conundrum and
people have debated these sorts of
things for a long time and I see that as
what's happening in this exclusionary
clause um we are deciding which babies
um we should say and which we should
throw under the bus and that's a very
difficult decision and and I don't I
don't blame anybody for taking the
opposite position I am but what's
happening here is that we are
potentially letting uh with if this
exclusionary clause days were
potentially letting intentional abusers
get away with their crimes so that they
can commit more
crimes in the hopes that
by by doing that that there will be
other parents who will feel more secure
in dropping off their babies without
fear of legal
repercussions and uh there's been a lot
of talk about who those parents might be
um a lot of parents you know they're
addicted to drugs and they just do not
have the wherewithal to take care of
their children and after a few days of
neglect they come to their senses thank
God that they need to they need to drop
off their baby and unfortunately there
has been there are concerns that law
enforcement will then use that
as as uh evidence to go prosecute them
for drug crimes okay and I'm against
that I have I have been openly against
the War on Drugs my entire life and I
don't like the idea of that
happening however the thought of a baby
being in the care
of a parent who is addicted to drugs and
is not capable of taking care of their
child that's a bad thought but it's not
as bad as a child being in the care of
somebody who is intentionally abusing
children that to me is a far worse
thought once again we're playing the
conductor con conundrum here ultimately
what it comes down to I see it is this
and that is there's a bad guy here
somebody is the bad
guy we are with B with baby boxes and
allowing parents to drop their children
off we are that's a pretty sweet deal
but by adding this exclusionary clause
what we're doing is we're sweetening an
already Sweet Deal we're saying not only
can you be a terrible parent but we're
gonna we're g to just look away from
Prosecuting you for uh for your misdeeds
and when we do that when we
when we Sherk our law enforcement job we
become the bad guy and the way I see it
is
that if we you know I would rather the
parents be the bad guys as opposed to us
being the Bad Guys by shering our
responsibility and
um well I'm sure there will be other
people that have some things to say and
I may have to chime in again but
ultimately um I'm not prepared to let
the state be the bad guys um I think
that oh and the last thing I'll say is
that when we fail to do our job uh when
law enforcement has their hands ties in
this regard it often will encourage more
lawlessness
and and I think that that's that's just
an unintended consequence I understand I
really do understand where the people
are coming from that support the
exclusionary clause but I think there
are going to be unintended consequences
we put in put that in there and I for
one
cannot put my stamp of approval on that
so much so that I happen to like the
rest of the bill but if that
exclusionary clause is in there I will
not be able to support the bill if if it
stays so that's why I've offered an
amendment that will help to get rid of
that exclusionary clause thank you for
listening to me for so long
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that and
thank you representative zth King for
following through on what you see as
your moral obligation to reduce harm I
see this essentially as a death penalty
bill um you have the potential that
children who are not surrendered
otherwise may be killed by their parents
and that's always a hard decision to
figure out where you are trying to
potentially let somebody who is a
monster not have appropriate punishment
for them if you look at some my mind
also went to those Deep Dark Places
about what somebody may do um I was in a
girl Scot Troop that had uh one of the
first women prosecute somebody for D on
here um judged and a lot of the ones
that literally I know the people that
are in the Forensic Files shows and I
watch too many of them so monsters exist
but there's a lot of people that because
of circumstances act like Monsters as
well but if they were given a chance
they wouldn't be a monster um I I'm not
convinced that by having this but not
having the exclusionary rule you'd still
have those monsters who may be serly
abusing children still forfeiting those
children so I'm not sure that those
children would be saved even by passing
this without the exclusionary rule but
what I do know is that people who are um
on the wrong side of the law they know
what happens they know through the gra
Vine what happens when somebody tries to
to do the right thing and then gets
popped for something IR related to it
I'm worried that if we don't have this
exclusionary law we're having the death
penalty for kids for parents who are
just so messed up that they're so afraid
of what's going to happen that they kill
their child instead of surrender them
and I recognize we may let some monsters
get away with horrible things but to me
the more run-of-the-mill situation where
somebody by circumstance dance acts like
a monster is a lot more pressing and
something that we have the ability to do
something about um I appreciate where
you're coming from and I think that you
know and I I apologize for not not
really crystallizing that I really see
this as a death penalty situation before
I apologize for not discussing that with
you before because until you were
discussing this I didn't realize that
really what we're doing is we're
deciding we're deciding when the death
penalty is appropriate because I see
that that is the other option for a lot
of these children that aren't
surrendered and to me I appreciate the
intent behind removing the exclusionary
but I I really think that we need it in
order to make sure that
run-of-the-mill unfortunately
run-ofthe-mill parents who just can't
take care of their kids who are
violating other laws um are more
comfortable surrendering their child
instead of destroying the evidence that
is that child so I I have to vote
against the amendment if the amendment
passes I have to vote against the ought
to passes amended because I think we
have an opportunity to save lives and
improve lives here and I wish I wish
there was an easier answer but but I
have to be opposed to removing that
exclusionary little representative uh
representative Merchant then
representative Missour thank you Mr
chair this is more of a procedural
question than anything
else the current law has lines 27
through 28 in the
law I supported the amendment because
there's a lot of concern on lines 29 30
and on top of page two because it
provided too much of a immunity to the
um to the
parents if we pass this amendment are we
therefore striking in the current law
lines 27 and 28 or we just striking 29
through the
end wases on thank you Mr chairman that
is an amendment to current law so if we
remove section six then the current law
which has those those lines 27 and 28
four yes that that removes the amendment
to current law that is in section four
so if we remove section four it's not
deleting um section RSA 132 D A4
liability which are those lines 27
through2 28 if we dilute Section 8 then
that remains in law unchanged thank you
because one of the concerns that we I
heard anyways I think we all did was the
concern about lines 2930 and the top of
page two and it gets back into the
possibility of having a conflict as far
as the ability for law enforcement it
was just a quag Mark um and I think
represent King is it it's one of those
things that we need to really think
through and way it's written right now I
think is
problematic um you know and law
enforcement came and said they had
concerns with it the Department of
Health Human Services had concerns with
it a lot of people had concerns with
that language that's in the Bold so by
deleting that I can move forward with
the bill I think the bill in line is
appropriate has a lot of merits to it
but i' be again i' be willing to work
with somebody to change the language
that we can work on but at this point in
time I can support the bill with the
amendment representative Missour thank
you Mr chair I heard the assumption that
placing a child in a safe haven box you
know means that the child is being
grossly abused that is an assumption
that's not always the case a child can
be placed in a safe haven box the parent
could simply be not simply but could be
struggling with taking care of that
child and simp just can't do it anymore
and is has to give that baby up it does
not mean that that child has necessarily
sure sometimes that would be the case
but it doesn't always mean that the
child is being neglected or abused and
such and such as we heard and that it
sounds like that's a lot where this
amendment came from um so that is an
assumption that is not always accurate
the amendment removes the
exclusion and places the consequence
over the life of the child and that is
something I cannot and will not support
um it's I we've said it before many
times as we've been talking about this
bill but I personally want a live baby
without
prosecution um or prosecution with a
dead baby and that's exactly what you
said the death penalty I mean that I I
that's something and so if this
amendment passes I will not be voting
for the bill as well because it
completely takes away from the heart and
soul of the
Bill thank you representative kofalt
then representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman so I I
guess I want to return to the the
logic U that the that sort of the basis
for this amendment because there is an
assumption that a parent well let me see
if I can figure out how to articulate
this if a if a
parent drops off a
child and there is evidence of abuse and
there is no exclusionary
rule then there is an opportunity to
prosecute that
parent um and use that
evidence if
they if they don't drop off the child
because it's clear that they they could
be subject to
prosecution it is it's highly likely
that they are not going to drop off the
child
there was a statement um at one point I
believe that or concern that would
people even be aware and I'm going to
say that I think word travels very fast
on the
street um all it will take is one
prosecution and I think that will put a
a a permanent end to the use of these um
baby boxes or safe
havens um
so you know on on the flip side to say
that we are allowing that person to
continue um to continue abusing um I
would actually argue that if we are not
accepting their decision
to surrender their baby we are allowing
them to continue abusing because they're
not going to surrender their baby they
are most likely if they're an abuser
they are going to abuse that baby
they're going to abuse that child for
many years
um this is the conundrum this is not I
mean just like the analogy that you
presented representative I think it is a
moral dilemma it's not an easy thing to
answer it is for me however
um I I will I will take the
uncomfortable Choice over over the what
I think what I personally believe is the
really really bad choice I would much
rather have that
baby in a safe place then allow that
that situation to continue uh and the
abuse to continue representative
Shapero yes thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for rep representative King
for um articul articulating in such an
eloquent way the almost impossible
dilemma that we have here
um so my question is for someone who is
um smarter than me
um since Roman numeral 1 is already in
statute and um what is added as Roman
numeral 2 on line 29 can somebody can
somebody articulate the difference
between the two of those I mean I mean
my impression is that we're giving
um greater immunity but I don't really
from just reading that I don't really
understand there's
already in statute is already a certain
immunity so if someone could explain the
difference between Roman numeral one and
Roman numeral 2 I would appreciate it
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that question
so this one does prohibit um in any
claim at law or an equity but it doesn't
have any claim that's for anything
that's through a rulemaking process so
if you look at it and you look at any of
the rules that would happen through dcyf
where they might go for other children
that are in somebody's care or go after
them through something that's in rules
we have a lot of other areas that are
addressed other than just law and Equity
we have a special committee on due
process and DF and there's a lot of
stuff that happens outside of the laws
that we set here in the legislature
there's a lot that we've just sort of
set to let them do um as part of their
process so this would allow for you know
if if you look at it too we had had uh
we had had people that were talking
about the necessity because they seemed
to be more interested in Prosecuting
parents than they were in getting the
children out of the situation that was
my read of the situation and that may
just because be because I'm so
concerned we we all look at the
potential risk and potential harm
separately I would rather have the child
out of the dangerous situation over the
prosecution but some of the testimony
was talking in a way that made me think
that they had different priorities so um
that's why I think that that the section
one that's already in law isn't enough
because they said that they they they
said that they were looking to go for
prosecution
representative shapo so so Roman numeral
one does not clude include immunity from
prosecution uh it was my understanding
that they were looking to to take action
against parents with what would be an
existing law so the existing law was not
going to preclude them from taking
action against parents I'm not a lawyer
and I don't know the difference between
all of these different aspects that's
why we're trying to get into it within
DC
but it sounded like if we kept the
language the same and remove section 4
if we kept those that those words in law
they would be able to take action
against parents even after they had
dropped off their child I'm not sure
exactly what action that would be but
they said that it would take away the
ability that they had with the current
law representative Kwal and then
representative Merchant um thank you so
the um so the answer is that under
current law criminal prosecution is is
indeed possible and that's what happened
in the do uh doino case I believe is the
last name um dates back two or three
years um and um yeah it was it was a it
it actually was a murder case not of the
child who was being dropped off but um
of a child that was pre previously in
that person's custody um but information
was collected during the um drop off
process and that sort of triggered a
a series of additional questions and
leading to that um the defendant in that
case said that she never would have
dropped off
her her baby at the safe haven had she
known that she would have been subject
to
prosecution representative
merchin thank you Mr
chair I have before me
at something maybe the committee wants
to discuss from me I could work with
senator represent King on Seth
King it basically says the parent acting
pursuant of this chapter should not be
subject to the petition under
RSA 169c alleging neglect based solely
on the actions described in this
chapters and that section by the way
goes back to the child protection act so
what I think what I heard before with
the attorneys is that if all of a sudden
through the investigation they find the
person has an issue with drug abuse
abuse or has been fraudulent about
certain things which has nothing to do
with the child that's the concern they
had because all of a sudden that
evidence they find is no longer
admissible that's not I think the intent
of what we're trying to do here we're
trying to protect the parent who decides
to drop a child off that protecting both
the parent and the child but not
absolving them of all the other things
that could come before such as they were
selling drugs illegally doing things if
you will that we need to protect because
if that's activity going on this masting
because of this dropping off the child I
don't want to prohibit that either so
maybe I can sit down with Seth Seth King
and we can work on maybe another
amendment to deal with
this okay our representative Shapiro and
then I'm before we go to your
representative uh we were just talking
and uh it's noon uh we were thinking
maybe continuing this discussion until
after we um we reconvene at 1:00 and
deal at 1585 but why don't you make your
your comment and U maybe during lunch
we'll we'll be able to come up with some
ideas too okay um so I'm not really sure
I understood the distinction between
Roman numeral one and Roman numeral 2
but um how however um I wonder if in
crafting a different amendment that
different kinds of law breaking could be
separated um so that somebody could not
um be prosecuted for letting
their you know for dropping their child
off
for unrelated crimes like I don't know
if they're unrelated but but crimes such
as drug use or drug selling or dealing
but that they could be still that there
could
be a narrow exception for if it was for
assault or abuse of the child and that
that would still not be excluded
representative and that's what basically
by exempting them from RSA 169c which is
child's protection act that means
anything in that act which deals with
the abuse of a child and so forth is not
admissible anything beyond that such as
they're dealing with drugs other illegal
activities is not
protected
right last comment representative copal
then we're going to continue this to
after lunch uh thank you Mr chairman so
I guess I would offer a scenario um
because I I I want to return to the idea
that this is excluding evidence that
emerges as a direct result of them
dropping off a baby aafe Haven it does
not offer it does not prevent
prosecution it simply excludes certain
evidence so if you imagine for example
um that a a mother is in an abusive
relationship
uh the the husband or boyfriend is is
abusive to the child child has bruises
the
mother has to ask the question if I
bring my child to the safe haven box
covered with
bruises am I am I going to now be a
suspect I I would I would expect so um
and am I now going to be potentially
subject to criminal prosecution imagine
that you know that that same child uh
was observed with bruisers
by a neighbor uh days before um
prosecution would still be
possible but they would have to exclude
the evidence that the child had bruises
when they were dropped in the safe haven
box so I mean it it's again we're sort
of coming up with scenarios here but I'm
concerned about the idea of um starting
to parse um different types of crimes I
think you know bottom line is I I I'm
I'm pretty firmly of the belief that you
know it's it's more important to protect
the life of a child um than do have a a
100% um prosecution record I think you
know we absolutely should hold people to
um to bring people to Justice um but if
if we have an opportunity to save a
child we should do that okay at this
point why don't we recess until 1 at
which time we'll take up 1585 and then
we will resume our discussion of 1607
subsequent to that so we'll stand in
p.m.
Roa you were here I believe to speak to
an
amendment um actually I can move her
Amendment actually so um I'll move that
I'll move that we adopt Amendment
0908 and hopefully there'll be a second
so we can discuss this representative
Shapiro second so please come forward
and thank you uh welcome and thank you
for being here could I also invite Miss
NATO who was part of the team that put
sure and for the arod what what's your
name again please my name is Sarah NATO
okay thank you
and are you with HHS or where are you
from I am the owner and administrator of
carage Hill assistant living in Madbury
okay thank
you so as a result of the um request
that the committee made regarding the
first amendment that was presented to
the committee a team was put together of
the
stakeholders for the um for the for the
amendment and it consisted of of the New
Hampshire Association of retired of of
sorry Residential Care um communities
the a Council on Aging DHHS
oplc um the Board of Nursing and the
association of nurses Nurses
Association because all these
individuals had concerns and really held
a piece of the necessary changes that
had to be made and um through through
significant hard work and a lot of of a
discussion the committee this sub
committee came together with an
amendment that's being presented towards
to you and um it's something that
everyone agrees with and I think that
it's an example of good legislation
because it does address a need that the
um that New Hampshire has and yet the um
Bill the amendment before you is um
something that all the
stakeholders are pleased with and if
you'd like to address any specific
questions or maybe Miss NATO can go over
the process that we used thank you
proceed Miss
NATO so be happy to give a quick summary
of the amendment so this bill is
regarding medication administration in
what are commonly referred to as
Assisted Living which are supported
Residential Care Homes or Residential
Care Homes um so current currently in
our facilities only RNs registered
nurses LPNs licensed practical nurses or
medication nursing assistants m&as are
allowed to administer medication to
Residents and that is one of the primary
reasons why a lot of our residents are
in assisted living is because they
either cognitively or physically need
assistance with medication
administration there is however a
significant Workforce Staffing issue so
it's a resident safety concern that we
do not have enough Staffing of our R NS
LPN and m&as to adequately staff our
facilities and therefore it puts
residents at risk for safe medication
administration So currently the pathway
for people to be able to administer
medications is either to be you
obviously an RN LPN or an m&a m&as are
lnas who have worked for at least two
it's roughly two two and a half years
full-time before they can qualify to
take the m&a certification course so we
have a lot of Staff who are nursing
students um going on to medical school
so for college students or even high
school students who have their LNA and
because they're pursuing higher
education goals they don't have the they
don't meet the hours requirement nor is
it fiscally ideal for them to also spend
the money and time to get those licenses
and yet they're a very qualified staff
to be able to safely administer
medication so we're trying to create a
different pathway so we will still have
the path of RN LPN or LNA to m&a to be
able to administer but we're also
creating a pathway where pcas Personal
Care assistants who are unlicensed staff
who do essentially the same role as
Lenas in our facilities to be able to
take a course that will be 40 hours long
um defined and approved by the Board of
Nursing it will be a certification so
that we do have safeguards in place such
that if they are not um if they have a
high number of medication errors or we
are
suspecting drug diversion or you know
situations like that there is a a board
and a license that would be able to be
uh revoked if um they are not meeting
you know satisfactory requirements so we
have sufficient safeguards in place
including continuing education eight
hours every two years specific to
medication administration so that we
feel that they are fully qualified to
safely administer medication so we have
called this new position a comma it's a
certified Assisted Living medication Aid
the staff would only be able to work in
the residential care or supported
residential care facility so Assisted
Living only they must be a direct
employee of the organization so they
can't be a home health care Aid that
comes in to provide care to a resident
they cannot be an agency staff member
they must be directly employed by the
residents and so we feel that this is
going to open opportunities attract more
people potentially to the healthcare
field but still be able to you know
safely administer medications to our
residents and that's a critical
component of what we do for our
residents on a daily
basis thank you any questions yes
representative notam uh thank you for
taking my question um so you know I've
visited people in in nursing homes and
um is a nursing home is it ass assisted
Assisted Living so there would be a like
a a medical room where all the drugs are
kept and would these people be you know
putting the pills into the little white
cups that then they go uh how how does
that work you know cuz I could yeah so
in the current roles that are defined by
the Board of Nursing there are different
levels of medication administration so
we do have some residents who are still
capable of fully self-administering
their own medication so if they have an
order by their provider that allows them
to keep it at their bedside they may
keep it in their room most of the
residents in our situation in my
building we our policy is that we fully
administer medication regardless of
their cognitive or physical status so it
depends on each home they can divise
their own policies so it can be
completely self- Administration it can
be medication with assistance but once
you get a Beyond fully self-
administering on your own you run into
the complications of it needing to be an
m&a an LPN or an RN to administer
because um even self- Administration
with assist with assistance has some
barriers like like they may be able to
rip the package but they can't put it in
their hand so there there's restrictions
so this would help um make make it such
that it's either fully self-
Administration or the colas would be
allowed to assist with the
medication followup representative not
so of course they're they're not decide
I mean the prescriptions are already
written out and filled so they're not
making decisions about
whether they just like you know 40
milligram two tablets which so that's
fairly simple to yes bottle white
correct so we are their home we're their
residents we are not a medical treatment
facility in the sense that we are
assessing diagnosing or prescribing all
of the medications that we're
administering have to be prescribed by a
provider and our staff are simply
following the instructions on the label
so we argue that if you are at home you
can take your own medication without a
class your daughter can set up your pill
box for the week your friend can do it
without any training exactly so this is
their home we are simply following the
orders most facilities also have an EMR
that helps with the that we also not all
of them but many of us use Pharmacy
services that prepack them so there are
a lot of safeguards in place but yes are
we are simply administering per the
instructions on the bottle if there were
a medical emergency we're calling 911 or
calling their physician we do not have
the ability to assess or prescribe okay
thank you you made that very clear
representative Nagel and then
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um I'm trying to understand and I think
I do but help me out is there what's the
difference between a certified
medication Aid and a
comma okay so in New Hampshire it's
licensed nursing assistants and they can
work in locations other than Assisted
Living so you can have lnas in the
hospital setting so so their scope of
practi is defined by the Board of
Nursing um the difference with a comma
is that they lnas have broader scope of
practice some of which would not be
applicable in our setting as opposed to
a hospital so the reason that's
important to have a separate and clearly
defined position that sist of living is
that an LNA would need to
um they don't use m&as in a hospital
setting lnas cannot pass medication in a
hospital setting so it's it's two very
different tracks only because lnas have
a broader scope of practice and can work
in settings other than Assisted Living
does that answer your question yes yeah
that's kind of what I figured I is there
a lure now for them so this is creating
the license it's creating the
license representative Merchant then
representative Thomas thank you Mr
chairman and also thank you for spending
a lot of time on this amendment one of
the things I don't see in here and I
apologize for not bringing it up to uh
president go Grody
earlier there's a limit there's no
limitation if you will on what drugs can
be administered it goes by the nursing
board my concern is that injectable
products because many times that's where
a lot of Errors can Gravely be made
there's nothing in this statute that
says they can that prohibits them from
doing it so should we be thinking about
somehow in inting some sort of language
to be sure that we're not talking about
injectable products talking about non-
injectable products yes so in the
current statute as it's written now it
says medications and it specifies uh
certain medications defined by route and
and dosage and that's where in the rules
we would be looking to Define that
further and we did make sure that Clause
was in there because we did have
multiple discussions about um that when
we get to defining it in the rules there
there is concern we all are in agreement
that it would not be injectables other
than potentially pens so yes we are all
in agreement those involved in the
committee that it would not include any
medications that you would draw up by
syringe um we would still have to Define
if everyone's comfortable with it being
for example insulin in a dialed up
pen follow thank you so in saying that
if that's the agreement of stakeholder
Community is there any harm by putting
that language into this amendment into
the bill to be clear about that sure um
no I think we would just have to have a
little bit more discussion on that as
the committee to be able to further
amend that but I don't think there would
be any opposition opposition to having
that defined further in the statute as
opposed to rule thank you representative
Thomas and then representative Leon
thank you Mr chair um thank you for
coming here um my question along the
lines of injectable medication is there
any concern for schedule one drugs with
these
people so we do do hospice and end of
life care and we do have residents who
are routinely prescribed uh narcotic
medications even if they're not on
hospice and there was not concern
because it's a very controlled
environment in our setting and again we
are strictly following the prescription
um you know the specific order by the
provider um but the reason we wanted to
make sure this was a licensed or
certified position is that so there
would be safeguards in place that is a
license that can be revoked if we have
concerns about issues such as drug
diversion representative L then
representative Shapiro um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you and everybody
else behind you for your hard work on
this um my mother-in-law went through an
assisted living facility and um we're
unsure if one of the chains of events
was about uh medications that either did
or didn't get to her or didn't or didn't
get there correctly um who ultimately
holds the responsibility if there's an
error by the comma and who would who
would who would be responsible yeah so
in the amendment we have specified that
they're reportable to the
administrator and we also specified that
there must be an either a physician MD
do APRN pa uh RN LPN must be available
for consultation 24 hours a day whether
in person electronically by phone so
that if there any question about the
specifics of the order they they would
be required to have somebody on call
avail able for that but ultimately it
does fall under the administrator to be
responsible for the medication errors
and also responsible for reporting um if
there should be any consideration of
revocation of the license or
certification what that followup and
then as a followup so that means that if
somebody is not giving them or giving
them wrong or something if it rises to
the a level of a legal claim against
them it would be the administrator that
somebody goes after because the
administrator is the one supervising
them yes okay thank you that makes a lot
of sense I just want to make sure that
ultimately there's somebody who's
responsible um for those edge cases to
hopefully prevent the edge cases
representative Shapiro and then
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking this
question you you partially answered this
question but I was wondering about the
24hour a day consultation and you you
already went over who those who who
provides that consultation but I don't
know how big your facility is but are
the facilities able to have access to
that kind of 24-hour day consultation is
that
like you know is it difficult to get is
it financially onerous is it really is
it available sure so my facility is 24
beds and I have a director of nursing
who's an RN and I have a associate
director of nursing who's an LPN
full-time in my building specifically I
employ four RNs and three LPNs
there are much larger facilities that
may even be stuffed 24 hours a day by an
RN but we also run the gamut and there
are some very small homes like six six
licenses six beds so we put it as
available by consultation so that if
they are interested in in having Kos
work for them they could contract with a
service that would provide that so it
specifically just states that they must
have someone available 24 hours a day
but it gives them flexibility whether
that's their own Staffing or somebody
that they could contract with to provide
that
service representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman uh answer
one of the questions about schedule one
drugs a pharmacy cannot dispense the
schedule one so if they're if I
understand it correctly you're only
dealing with prescriptions dispense by a
pharmacist correct so therefore it would
exclude gu one okay number two the
administrator for the facility are they
required to have a license what I'm
trying to get to is that if we're going
to hold them accountable outside of a
liability point of view do they have a
license that is at risk so I am an
administrator we do not hold licenses
but we are named on our license with
DHHS so when we apply for our license
with DHHS to operate our CST of living
we have to name an administrator who is
who is liable and responsible for the
facility So I myself don't hold license
but I I am the administrator named on my
facilties
license follow so what I'm trying to get
to is what's the risk factor for the
administrator outside of liability I
mean a lot of times when you have a
license that's at risk you may perceive
things differently than if you don't
have one so if there's no license for
the administrator to lose um outside of
a liability issue that's my concern so
I'm not quite sure where to go with that
sure I'm not sure if it would be okay I
know licensing is here from DS I don't
know if Kelly Keith is able to better
answer that question if she might be
allowed to answer
that I think it would be helpful if I
made chairman is that if if there's a
way to say if something happens that you
cannot hold another license or you can't
be an administrator at at that facility
or any other facility that way there be
it some way to um be sure you have S
game good afternoon for the record my
name is Dorian shley I'm the manager of
the Bureau of Licensing and
certification at DHHS to answer your
question representative Merchant
unfortunately that's not a question that
I could answer it sounds more of a legal
question is terms of liability um I can
say that from the facilities lens we
license Health Facilities we don't
license individuals so the administrator
on record for all licens facilities is
the person responsible for all
operations and activities that occur but
in terms of what um representative Lon
and you are asking that sounds more like
a legal question um um from a liability
for the individual so I'm not I'm not
able to answer that question but it's a
very good
question representative Seth King thank
you Mr
chair um to piggyback on what the last
two representatives were talking about
my understanding is that um nurses
um at these assisted living facilities
they spend really the majority of their
time handing out medication and and
dealing with medication and they're
constantly at fear of losing their
license um be even if one little thing
goes wrong even if a pill goes missing
they're afraid that that could cost them
their license and that you know
if if the C if these new commas don't
have that that sort of Sword of damic
hanging over their head all the time
then it's just an interesting something
to think about I I'm not taking a
position on it one way or the other um
and my question though for you is that I
just imagine that if this new Cola
position were created that you could
reduce you said you had four nurses you
could potentially reduce three of those
nurses positions and and replace them
with kma because they're like I said so
much of their time is spent doing out
medication that if you if you use these
you you'd you know you wouldn't need so
much nursing uh manh hours um so could
you address that a little bit um and as
well as the the licensing issue that the
that the nurses fear of losing thank you
sure
so my RNs are not full-time just a quop
that not full-time FTE but that is
really the heart of this issue is that
there is a a major shortage of nurses
LPN and m&as such that we are struggling
to staff our facilities so it's a
resident safety issue caused by the lack
of Staffing so we compete with hospitals
and nursing homes for nursing staff and
there I for myself my facility went four
years almost four and a half years
through covid where I constantly had
open positions that I could not fill for
what we generally classifies as Med
givers um so that that is really the
concern and the impus of this bill
um the whole goal here is to create a
safe pathway and of course where they
are going to get 40 hours of training to
be able to safely and effectively pass
those medications because we are not
able to successfully staff and fully
staff our facilities and therefore
putting residents at risk so yes it
would allow me to use the staff that is
a goal instead of nurses and so forth
and I think as you all are aware we have
a major health care Staffing crisis in
this us we have one of the oldest
populations here in New Hampshire we're
at the beginning of the Baby Boomers so
we're trying to get ahead of this by
creating this position so that we do
have the available Staffing to safely
administer medications to our residents
and as I mentioned before this is their
home um we at home they're allowed to
take it we feel that a 40-hour class for
our staff who are doing this as their
full-time job are are going to be safely
qualified to do this and that it's not
necessarily the best use of a nurse in
our building um just to be used to pass
out medication as far as the license I
can say that
um oh okay um Elizabeth from oplc would
be able to answer more specifically the
questions that you have related to the
license and the cola and the
liability Elizabeth Eaton uh Council to
the board of nursing uh in the Board of
Nursing w p in as a stakeholder because
uh due to the concerns about
accountability for this new position um
and so the Board of Nursing um not only
elected to um be the the jurisdiction
over this position but is eager to um
they understand the the
shortage uh
and so I want to make make it clear that
these are this is in the nurse Practice
Act they would have jurisdiction and so
a complaint could come in about a c
who um is not passing out pills or is is
somehow um messing up uh and and it
would come to the Board of Nursing and
they would uh
sanctions okay um well representative B
did you have your hand up earlier or no
oh okay representative Merchant thank
14 on page
one instead of saying certified by the
office licensed by the office that way
there they have a license and therefore
that could be pulled by the Board of
Nursing so in uh
541a the definition of license includes
the word certification and so a
certification even though it's it sounds
different from a license it is
considered in New Hampshire a license
and so it's no different from uh a
licensed nursing assistant or a
certified
uh Assisted Living medication assistant
they they hold the same kind of license
so thank you so if they're synonymous is
there any reason we could not change
licensed I that's something for the
group to discuss I think walma sounds a
so
I'm seeing no other
amendment seeing none representative
South
King yeah um I don't know how I'm going
to vote on this amendment it's sort of
it's sort of last minute and I was
originally TP on the the main bill
because it was so clean and simple and
there's at least it seemed like it there
was and there's um there's a lot here um
and I I kind of have mixed feelings
about it I mean on the one hand um I I
like the idea because I I do recognize
that the nurses they're they're totally
underst staffed and they're maybe even
more prone to making mistakes because
they're so understaffed and um this
could help free up
some of the problems we see in assisted
living
facilities I don't know um I have mixed
feelings I'll probably go along with it
though okay other discussion
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um are we inventing something or does
this Exist
Elsewhere um so we are inventing
something well we're taking something
copying something that already exists in
Maine um and I believe just Maine right
now Maine and Massachusetts but I also
kind of wanted there's a lot lot more
people here than at the session that we
were at um at the end of January I
believe it was or we're just in a much
smaller room so I wanted to give a
little okay very good then because I
just wanted to give a little history
actually to representative King to your
point um we had come in front of the
committee with the First Amendment um I
think it was the end of January because
we were asked at that that point we
actually did suggest or recommend that
it go to study committee um and that the
group behind me and others that aren't
here get together and kind of explore
this because it's very large and it's
very important um we were advised at
that meeting to come up with a report to
present to you today um um
representative Shapiro asked if we could
do that soon we said sure um and so
through that process we ended up
surprisingly
with an agreed upon amendment to create
an entirely new position in the state of
New Hampshire that replicates what's in
Main and Massachusetts that's working
well for them so I just want to give a
little bit of context we're certainly
open to studying this more but really
believe if something's working in our
sister states that it would be something
that we would want to consider doing
helpful they're not listening so I can
ask it is
does let's try to sneak her in there so
the the um the 40-hour course does that
exist already or will that have to be
created it will be created and do you
know what a time frame for that would be
um well I think the amendment says this
act takes effect 60 days after its
passage
so I think we have a lot of that
done it's a lot of un yes as quickly as
we POS we did a lot of work really fast
so I'm hoping that we would do the same
going forward and it's a very um it's a
collaborative group across all agencies
that have worked really well together
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair I noticed in the original Bill
there was rule making Authority given to
the board of
nursing but in the amendment that goes
away so I want to be clear we don't lose
that rule making Authority by inserting
the amendment because it's basically
replace all
so I want to be sure that we don't
somehow inadvertently not give the Board
of Nursing rulemaking authority to
Etc give me a moment to find where it is
in the um in the amendment but the rule
there
I mean if you're inserting this the
nursing practice and if it isn't well so
here's what it is here's where it is
they they already have rule making
Authority for all
licenses um for all persons licensed
under this chapter and so under uh
326b uh any any license type they have
rule making authority over and so they
didn't feel the need to to
specify I I would I would caution
against that um I think it be if you're
not opposed to it to insert language in
there that's very clear you have
rulemaking authority because I know
sometimes legislative body has a
tendency to not look at when it it's the
Jael car and want to be clear that you
have Ru making Authority in the act
itself and not something referring back
to a broad grou making Authority just to
be on the safe side thank
you other
questions apparently I do representative
Nel your microphone is on and your hand
is sorry I've been urged by one of my
colleagues to ask you what they call
this in other states and what the
acronym
is so Maine used a certified medication
Aid and we are advised to not use that
because it's too close to CRNA a
certified nurse and nus sorry CNA a so
that's why uh we deviated from that we
also wanted to be very clear that this
role can only work in HP 804 and 805 the
supported Residential Care Homes that we
made sure we put assist of living in the
title so that it was very clear that
that is the only place this license
effect other
questions seeing none
okay thank you uh any other discussion
on this amendment one question that has
been
raised and is Christina back
there
um well and and you probably can't
answer this there's a question as to
whether this amendment would be
considered a Germain Amendment or not
where it creates a new
position yeah well we're we're doing
that right now but I didn't know if you
that
okay yeah that we're doing that right
now but I I didn't know if you had any
thoughts or any insights on
it yeah I would uh I would think that
you representative we is a co-sponsor
and she usually has a pretty good sense
of these things
also um Mr chairman yes when I look at
the original bill it's referencing a
different RSA which is facilities this
is referencing something more towards
the Board of Nursing so I do I think
having the clerk weigh in on this would
probably be be helpful and wise okay all
right again we're emailing him right now
answer okay um all right so obviously we
we can't really vote on this at the
moment
um I guess what we could do is revisit
16007 in the interim and um and then
come back to
this representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman I just have a question about
procedure um if it's not a if it is a
Germaine Amendment there were
two smallest changes that were brought
up one about injectable medications and
one about um Ru making Authority um is
there any way to vote on this amendment
and have those put in later or would we
have to have the amendment re written to
include those well once once we vote on
this bill we're done with it in term
representative Lon um I think we need to
have that drafted and I know that OS is
um they're working to get everything to
everybody who needs last minute things
right now so we I think we'll find out
if this is Germaine or not and if it
needs a if it does need to have a
separate hearing and um regardless we'll
probably want to end up executing this
one on the 20th most likely just so that
we have a chance to digest it even if it
is ger I mean I like it a lot um but I
just want to make sure we're doing
everything in the right process and we
don't end up having a wrench thrown into
the works of the last minute and lose
all of this really important valuable
work I just hope that we can ascertain
that we're all in agreement today with
the rewriting so that we don't have to
relitigate the whole thing on the
20th I I know that I personally am I
guess if anybody has any questions I'm
sorry I'm try not trying to jump in on
this um we we probably would be able to
hit a calendar deadline if we do this
quickly to have an non derain hearing
we'd be able to have those of us who
need to be here for it and then having
an exec on the 20th would be my thought
just to make sure we're doing everything
on the up and up but if anybody wants to
speak up especially if they have
palaza I support moving it to 20 but uh
I I don't see the need to further amend
like uh like was said because it's
already in this chapter it's already on
under this board so uh I don't think we
need those two amendments to this amend
Amendment but it's just my
opinion
discussion okay well I I sense that we
want to move this to the uh there's
enough concern to move this and continue
it to the 20th where we have several
other uh bills already certainly not a
whole day's worth but we we will be
meeting on the 20th so uh but I would
need a motion I would I would need to
have you withdraw your motion I with
withdraw my motion and who seconded to
that sh representative Shapiro you
withdraw your second all right so we'll
continue HB 1585 to um we'll continue
that till the 20th thank you everyone
who testified and and offered
information
today okay moving on uh we'll find out
about again about the not that amendment
is Germain all right let's get back to
16007 then representative oth King thank
you Mr chair um after having um done
some discussion with representative
Merchant um I've decided to withdraw my
motion of the amendment so that
hopefully we can get a some time in
discussing discussing this in a little B
further deta detail maybe we come up
with a different amendment to to that so
for now I'd like to just withdraw my
motion yeah who made that second I did I
will also withdraw okay so that
amendment is no longer before us uh so
what is the thought is that this also
something we're going to continue or we
want to continue or yeah that would be
um so that we can continue this on the
March 20th yeah
okay
okay well March 20th is getting to be a
busier and busier
day a long day it's okay okay moving on
then uh the next bill up is um
1615 representative kofalt I believe you
motion I do um I have an amendment which
that's
those
um um so I I'm move ought to pass with
amend Amendment
H um is there a second second
representative Merchant seconds uh
representative cofell do you want to
speak to your motion sure so
um you may recall that during the
hearing um the Bill's original sponsor
indicated that the uh his preference
actually would have been to repeal the
autism registry outright
uh the department weighed in and said
that they were unaware of anyone using
the registry for data
analysis um they don't have any
objection to repealing it and um I also
spoke with two co-sponsors of the bill
who also believe that an outright repeal
would actually be preferable to the bill
that was presented um I think they they
didn't go that far with the original
Bill simply because they the the prime
sponsor didn't think that was
necessarily achievable uh but having
spoken to a number of uh a number of
people it seems like this is the
preferred option so uh briefly stated
what this bill does is it repeals the
autism registry it repeals rulemaking
relative to the autism registry and it
directs the Department of Health and
Human Services to make reasonable all
reasonable efforts to destroy the data
the individual data records um that
means means that they could retain
aggregate information total number of
people diagnosed with autism in any
given year but they would be destroying
the the the records that pertain to
individuals um you know one of the key
concerns here of course is that um it
came to light in the in the hearing that
there's a great deal of personally
identifiable information in that
registry and that nobody is giving
consent to be added to the registry uh
in fact many of them are not aware that
they or their family members are in the
registry so for that reason um I bring
this amendment which modifies the bill
to Simply repeal the registry Al
together okay any other discussion
representative
paza
um I I like the intention but um I
probably will vote against it because
I'm concerned about an intended
consequences to tax space and uh it
could be twofold first of all there's a
interest uh if there's a growing problem
for example of occurence of
autism uh there's a an interesting to
figure it out like some would say it's
completely not connected for example to
vaccination but let's prove it uh yes
the HHS maybe not using that registry
for this purposes
maybe maybe it should so that's
concerned that instead of trying to
figure out the problem we are destroying
data that
potentially um uh bring awareness of
what's going on and why it's going on uh
and the second
concern is like receiving Ser services
so um potential abuse when
person um or family want to receive
Services uh for
certain uh medical condition but then
they also want to receive other
services uh uh saying that they don't
have this condition so uh having it both
ways uh it's second potential unintended
uh so uh
I I I'm thanking for your effort uh in
uh supporting uh uh uh autism Community
uh but um uh for me it's not clear how
it will be uh with unintended
consequences thank
you representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um this is a question for for you
um so in in my town we have past
contamination and chronic past exposure
is is associated with autistic
Tendencies so I understand getting
getting rid of this list I I agree with
it however is there a vehicle that
remains in New Hampshire to gather
information including personal
information on autism so that we can
correlate it to
exposure thank you for the question so
I'm
um I'm not aware of what the Department
of Education has in terms of the
comprehensive nature of their data and
I'm not
sure to what extent they're barred from
sharing that data
um so because the autism
registry tracks diagnosis not
um it tracks diagnosis so there there
are potentially people who lived in a
certain
town were exposed to something and moved
or got vaccinated or not and moved
it does I guess doesn't it's not
relevant in that that case but there may
there may or may not be records in New
Hampshire of an event that could be
correlated um so I guess the short
answer is no but I also don't think that
the current data necessarily sheds much
light on on some of this I think it
certainly doesn't shed any light on
vaccination uh correlating uh because
there's no flag in there
currently for what vaccines a child has
has received
um so I I I guess the biggest concern is
that you know
the it the registry currently includes
the last four of people's social
security number it includes the town the
age the you know there's there's so many
variables that it includes that
um a you know a reasonably determined
person could could back into you know
personally identifying the people on the
list um so I I although I certainly
appreciate the intent behind the
question I think the answer is no and
and I'm not sure that this uh data is
would necessarily help I I wonder if
there was
another I see another hand up over
here representative
Shapiro I think maybe representative
kofalt covered it but when
DHHS testified about this original bill
um they said that there were other
um efforts to um keep track of of autism
I think mostly through special education
I understand from our researcher that
memo
any other representative n Ram thank you
um in this committee we've tried to
start Registries for several other
conditions ALS whatever so I was um
touched or something by the parents that
came to testify to say they didn't want
this registry so I'm going to go with
the parents that you know they've they
have the lived experience of um their
child with autism and they didn't want
this registry so I'm going to
vote accordingly okay thank you other
discussion seeing none okay the motion
is off to pass on
hb650 hyen FN uh the amendment
amendment CL call the
RO representative
yes representative Bo yes representative
Bill King yes representative kopal yes
representative liwicki
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
Representative peloso
no representative
Canon
yes representative Thomas
yes representative McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative period gri
yes representative Palmer
yes representative TZ yes and
representative McDonald yes 19 to
one okay do I have another motion
representative Kofa I move to pass with
Amendment second okay motions been made
and seconded any other
discussion motion is ought to pass as
amended on hp1 1615
FN uh if there's no discussion I'll ask
ready represent Lan yes representative
bone yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
lowii
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes Representative
pza
no representative
Canon
yes representative Thomas
yes representative M
yes representative fedus yes
representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Harriet gathre yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ yes and represent McDonald yes 19
to1 okay is there any objection if that
goes on consent actually is that
appropriation on
that no we can always try and they can
pull it off consent if we the RO okay
happens there you go there you go well
every time you see an F in you know you
have to get a little
nervous all
right oh well we don't get nervous
around you
though uh so the final bill of the day
to be considered is HB 1683 FN
representative
Lon um yes um I sorry I have it in my
paper I'd like to move Amendment
0573 and sorry I I thank you this should
be coffee not water um I would like to
move Amendment
0573 H and I'll pull that out of my
it like I said it should be coffee not
Amendment
we did what did we do we continued it we
didn't which one um the safe haven we
continued it okay we didn't I thought we
were going to discuss another question
well we did but they're not ready for it
yet another one another one that we had
but it's going to be about six bills on
that
day which is certainly
doable but that mean six reports that
have to be written right away that
day
yes uh we uh that was
consent that was an easy one 1712 the
amendment um we couldn't do because it
was chapter law not statutory so we
consent uh well Chris you'd like him
today right so you can get him in the
that probably they probably won't make
it
then because they've got to go from you
to Paul to the
speaker so all right but um yeah I
mean I don't know today tomorrow I would
guess they I know we have session but
Joe yeah we'll go over that so as we get
this last build done I'll go over what
um and I guess uh if I can get sort of
nods or any of that once people have
read through this so that I can then
talk through it I know I just didn't
want to talk while everybody was reading
but I guess we have it in front of us
now um what one of the concerns had been
um other medically necessary conditions
so on lines four and five it adds or any
diagnosed condition for which a
circumcision is deemed medically
necessary by a physician or other
healthcare provider license in New
Hampshire the other concern was
regarding the um was regarding the fact
that there was prior authorization and
uh line seven amends the bill to remove
the prior authorization requirement
so those were the two main main issues
that were raised on um the substance in
those areas um which were may not just
which would be uh more technical issues
differences representative
Merchant I want to say thank you to
representative Bon for the amendment um
one of the things I have in my notes and
maybe something that is not gerain here
it's also for religious reasons
so this this is medical what you
understand but there could be certain
religions that may either require it or
want it and so forth is that going to be
covered um if I can answer that in my
understanding the religious
circumcisions don't happen in the
hospital the religious circumcisions
happen outside of the hospital with a
non-medical
provider
okay well okay so then we need to get
into the other philosophic
question philosophically we have
problems with money say education money
going to religious institutions when
you're looking at this religious thing
the question is um you're looking at
Medicaid going for something that's
purely religious as opposed to something
that has some sort of medical
requirement so when you get to a purely
religious ritual type um circumcision
those ones are absolutely happening
outside of the hospital when there's the
general leaning just like the times when
I filled out on the religious for
generic Christian that's what I had
filled out you know it's there's the
question of there of how closely tied it
is so I I don't know if there's still
more concern but we're trying to get as
much as we can I would say based upon
this if I may sure go ahead thank you
that you raised a good point in what I
lost sight of Medicaid is medical
insurance and only can be used for
medical reasons so given that statement
and what you just said I could support
Shapiro I was just going to as the
committee Jew I was just going to
clarify that
um so um in the Jewish religion is one
of the religions along with um Islam
where people are
frequently circumcised and I I think
there's a great
variation um frequent ly circumcisions
happen in a ritual manner outside the
hospital but I think there were a lot of
Jews who believe that their children
should be certified who may be more
secular or might not be having that kind
of
ritual
um tradition and might have their child
circumcised in a doctor's office or um
in a
hospital to me that's not it's not
really the relevant point in terms of my
um feelings about the bill in general so
I don't I don't really think that that's
an issue we should do on representative
Seth King thank you Mr chair thank you
for bringing forth this amendment um I
definitely like the part of line seven
um by getting rid of that one part that
it does um Roman Roman five um I'm just
curious K says or any diagnosed
condition and I'm just wondering why we
leave in all of these these other um
specified conditions if we're going to
have like a catchall phrase anyways why
not just get rid of a through J and then
just make K the it's got to be medically
necessary why do we have to specify all
the other
ones uh well thank you that that that is
definitely one point of being able to
just wipe all of those out and say just
medically necessary but we also look at
the fact that we had another bill on
informed consent and recognizing that
there are medically necessary reasons
for circumstance de ision I think just
into that whole dialogue that hopefully
we don't keep rehashing but into that
whole dialogue it does put in statute
that there are those required there are
those medical reasons for it as well and
I think that that just sort of helps in
the conversation um nobody really prints
out very rarely are the statutes printed
out so I'm not going to worry too much
about the amount of ink by having those
additional lines um and this was one
that was proposed by the prime sponsor
um AV way to address the concerns
representative uh anagel then Shapero
thank you Mr chairman um I had a
question about what's your replacing on
Section Five um from the original bill
pre-authorization um so a
pre-authorization is when you need to
make sure you get approval before you do
something if you're going to get paid
for it at least that's my understanding
because we use the term prior I've never
used the term pre and that's why I was
confused by that whether it's a
pre-authorization from the patient or a
pre-authorization from the
insurer um I'm not sure if the language
in the bill is the correct language but
either way it's gone okay perfect if you
answer my question it solve my problem
thank you representative
Shapiro yes so I I'm going to vote
against this amendment and um it has
nothing to do with um religion or
religious um exception not being
included
um
you
know when one um is um looking for
information outside their area of
expertise um I don't know about you but
I tend to go on the internet and you um
one looks and clearly you can find
information on the internet that says um
circumcision is not only
unnecessary but um is damaging is
mutilating the body etc etc um that
there are no health benefits but I think
most of us would acknowledge that you
can also find information that says that
there are medical benefits and
um so I mean we could argue I don't
think we're equipped to argue what which
is true or more accurate and um I'm not
really interested in that but I would
say that in my mind
circumcision
is not a cosmetic procedure but it is an
elective procedure and I do not think
that people that boys should get
circumcised um I do not think that they
shouldn't be circumcised I think it's
parent choice I think a reasonable
parent could feel that
um there is some medical benefit and a
reasonable parent could feel that it it
could be potentially very damaging
although in my mind some of the stories
that we heard were full of hyperbole but
um so I think it is an elective
procedure I think um people are doing a
good job about educating people and
maybe there's more that could be done
about in in terms of Education um you
know I once again you can read all kinds
of rates but I think the rates have come
down from like my generation where 85%
of of boys were getting circumcised to
now it's more like 50% so things are
changing the Norms are changing and I
think it's probably a good thing and I
think it's probably because people um
take bodily autonomy more seriously and
people do a lot more research into their
own Medical Care and so I think that
that's probably a good thing and I think
education is a good thing however I
think that this has been a culturally
acceptable procedure
um I think it's been one can make the
argument that it has medical
benefit and I I'm against from an equity
point of view um taking that
reimbursement away from low-income
people so I would vote no on um ending
the coverage Medicaid coverage for
circumcision another
discussion representative B thank you
and you mentioned
represent mentioned Islam for example
but nothing in this bill that I read
says mail there are female
circumcisions so I mean so what are we
covering here males on females or both
and I know Islam had the thing in some
countries of female circumcision
so we have a problem here I think
representative
Shapero
I I believe that we have a New Hampshire
circumcision yeah I that I don't know
any other discussion representative
Merchant thank you Mr
chair like my colleague from Keane
initially was opposed to this bill
because concerned about creating two
classes of Medical Care those for the
wealthy and those who aren't but given
the fact that we Chang this to a any
diagnostic condition and based the fact
based upon the fact that
Medicaid the way it's written is only
for medical
procedures um I could therefore support
the bill particularly with line seven
deleting the reference to a prior
authorization so I will be in support of
the amendment probably for the bill okay
thank you representative Nel about the
amendment correct not the actual bill
because I count issues the bill itself
but any other discussion on the
amendment seeing none I'll ask the clle
to call the rooll the motion is ought to
pass on Amendment
H representative Leon yes representative
bone yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
licki yes
representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative palov
yes representative Canon
yes representative Thomas
yes representative McKay
yes representative prus
yes representative n upam
no
representative Shapiro no representative
Merchant
yes represent Palmer
yes representative tez yes and
representative McDonald
yes 18 to
two uh do I have another motion
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass as amended
by Amendment uh
05738 on House Bill
1683 and I will also second that as I
did the amendment uh any discussion or
would you like to speak to your motion
um thank you yes I would like to speak
very briefly to this motion I'm sure
none of you after getting to know me
would be surprised to know that I came
with binder like this with clinical data
when I went to the hospital with my kids
so I I recognized the idea and now there
was clinical equivalence that was
actually something that I supported and
I even had to get some exceptions to
other things in order to do that um as
for the idea about the potential of this
being discriminatory um I think that
everybody is coming to more awareness of
this and
I I think that this remains a personal
choice and I think that it's one that
because Medicaid is for medical reasons
any parent who's seeking it for medical
reason which you can find in the
literature and you can support and if
there's a parent who is really saying
this is really important to me as
they're being informed about the risks
and the benefit of the procedure the
doctor will tell them about the
potential data where they could be fewer
UTI if they were to get a circumcision
so I feel that any parent who feels very
strongly would be able to have a medical
indication that they could express to
the parent yes that the doctor that yes
that is important to me so I feel for
those parents who really feel strongly
they will have there is CL clinical
equivalence at you know at least about
it that they'll be able to point to
something um my other concern too is
that if it's just sort of a a one-way
conveyor belt where many where you're
finding people who are on private
insurance making more stopping and
thinking about the decision more than
people who are on Medicaid if it's just
B basically part of an established
pathway that you may see some difference
in equity around what the rates look
like in the Medicaid population versus
the non-medicaid population I don't want
to do that study I don't want to look at
that study but since Medicaid is for
medical reasons and everybody's evolving
in their Viewpoint I don't think that
it's a discriminatory
Bill representative Nagel and then
representative Merchant thanks Mr
chairman since I lost so much sleep over
this bill I just wanted to point out a
couple things that I think are somewhat
less relevant now with the amendment
which I actually do like but um this
bill only applies to Medicaid so what I
I tried to do is figure out well how
much does it actually cost to get a
Medicaid circumcision and it's actually
you it's a money loser the doctor doors
don't make any money doing this the
states that have actually done this have
seen the rate of Medicaid um
circumcisions drop by about 50% and what
was really interesting is when they
looked at two of those States the
Medicaid um reimbursement for
circumcision actually increased and the
reason why was because they weren't
doing it in newborns now they were doing
it in three or four year olds when the
risk benefit ratios and the cost benefit
ratios are a lot less favorable and so
they were dealing with a much more
expensive much more risk
procedure um so if this is supposed to
be a money saving Bill I'm not sure
anybody's going to be really saving any
money by doing it uh by passing this
bill and I kind of get the impression
that was the reason for the bill in the
first place the last thing I did want to
point out that I thought was also
important that I thought the testimony
that we heard for several hours was a
little bit misleading and them claiming
that this is a cosmetic procedure
without any medical benefit and then
they cited all the major medical
organizations that's not what the
medical organization said the American
Academy of Pediatrics said that the risk
benefit ratio actually favors doing this
in the newborn but the the benefit is
not sufficient to justify Universal
recommendation except in a couple
circumstances which the World Health
Organization the CDC vot set followed up
on is that if you live in an AIDS
endemic area you should do this in a
newborn because your risk is unfavorable
um if you live in a you know an STD
unfavorable environment that you
probably should do it because the risk
benefit ratio is more favorable in those
regards after that I agree it's a
personal choice but to this diminish
this is genital mutilation and cosmetic
is really
inaccurate representative Merchant then
representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair my
understanding of Medicaid I don't have
the
um depth of knowledge maybe I should
have to make the comment but thing I've
learned about
Medicaid is it's medical insurance and
the only time medical insurance will pay
for something with it's private or
public is when it's medically
necessary if it's something selective
and not medically necessary and cosmetic
and so forth most private insurance
companies along with Medicaid will not
pay for it so my concern of having two
levels of care based upon that comment
basically goes away given the fact we
don't have prior approval or prior
authorization ation required anymore I
feel comfortable that we are not
creating two classes of care um if the
medical provider deems it to be
medically necessary Medicaid will pay
for it if they deem it not to be
medically necessary need something
selective based upon either religious
reasons or other reasons whatsoever um
that's really up to the parent to make
that choice just like they would with
private insurance so I don't think this
is going to be a two two-tier system of
care representative
chaparo
yes I would like to address the equity
issue or as representative Leon said the
issue of whether it's discriminatory or
and I would say that if we pass this
bill we're essentially saying that that
it's not medically necessary and we're
passing a bill to say Medicaid no longer
will cover um
circumcisions and
um now you can read the fine print but I
think what we're basically saying to the
state of New Hampshire is that this is
um this is a procedure that that
Medicaid will not cover anymore and
that's the message that we're given um
and that it will be left to anybody who
is um I mean we don't want it to be that
the default def is to kids just get
circumcised but we don't want it to be
the default that kids don't get
circumcised and that a parent has to
bring their case to a physician and
saying well here's the research here's
what I think um is the medical benefit
so I think that it is an an equity issue
and that we are taking away a coverage
so I mean I know is I I disagree and I
think that I will I will definitely vote
against
this other
discussion oh representative Leon um
thank you Mr chairman and and thank you
for that I think that I I think that
this isn't something that's about the
funding and trying to save money for
Medicaid as much as it is to have a
discussion that it's not a default one
way or the other but it's a discussion
so I think that I believe that all
families a ball inome levels are capable
of having these discussions and talking
with their health care provider and that
through the whole process especially
when you do have a multi-day stay with a
with a birth that you have this
opportunity to talk with your Healthcare
team and have a discussion about the
need for about the medical reasons
behind circumcision um I
I I don't think it's discriminatory to
say that families regardless of their
income level are able to make decisions
about their child's care and um I know
this is is just one of those areas where
we just have different approaches to
trying to respect people and to respect
where they're coming from and I think I
don't think that we'll ever come to an
agreement on this but I know that we're
both coming from this from good good
points of view where we're both trying
to honor those families and make sure
that we're they're protected we just
disagree on how to do
that representative
Palmer so I do think the amendment helps
the bill but I'm opposed to the idea uh
most of the decisions about what's
covered or not are not legislated
they're made by groups of people who get
together with all the evidence and
decide whether or not a procedure is
coverage insurance coverage for the
procedure whether it's Medicare private
insurance or Medicaid and I think the
two things
that go here is one is that that with
more information the trend is is going
away from doing C circumcision but I
don't think I don't think we should
legislate
coverage I think that the coverage
should be decision should be made at you
know not not by legislators legislators
most of whom like even I don't this is
not something I do so I really don't
know about it so I don't think I should
be deciding
Shapero um I would just say
that that
um
in in terms of the message to the public
we' be passing a bill that says this
bill Pro the analysis this bill provides
that the State Medicaid plan shall not
include
circumcision and then it goes on to
unless their exceptions and so I think I
um I think this is a bill that that will
make it very hard for someone to um be
reimbursed for this procedure and
um and I don't know I don't understand
why we're doing that representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman thank you
represent chapero I went online just out
of curiosity Anthem will only pay for
circumcision if it's medically
necessary so back to the issue I think
we're race faced with here represent
Palmer we don't have an insurance
company this was an insurance company
sitting around the table deciding upon
what we want to cover Through the
policy and that's how insurance
basically Works however because we don't
have a corporation per say we are in a
sense the corporation legislatively so
we have to decide legislatively what we
want to put into the policy that we
cover for Medicaid patients so that's
where that's where I'm coming from and I
looked at Anthem a lot of the other ones
they don't pay for it unless it's
medically necessary so what I'm trying
to make an argument for is that we're
following the free market as well so
somebody unfortunately was going to be
an Anthem because they made too much
money going to Medicaid they could have
the procedure done at least be paid for
by somebody else representative bmer and
then representative sharo but I I wonder
how an Anthem would respond if we
not respon representative it it's a good
it's a good point I hear but we're not
legislating
who should we turn it over to the
Department of Health Human Services and
agency let them decide what the policy
should be someone's going to make a
choice about the policy and there's no
we don't have a corporation to make that
decision so how do we do it otherwise
How would how would you do
it
representative well so Medicare makes
its own decisions I mean why don't we k
i I mean I I'm just saying we we can't
as a legislative body to sit down and
take all of the medical diagnos noes and
decide which ones we're going to pay for
we're not qualified to do that maybe we
need maybe there needs to be you know a
commission or something a group that
does that for Medicaid I don't know to
be honest I don't know how it works now
but I I just don't like the idea of
starting to take pieces of
it and and you know who knows what the
next one will be where Medicaid's not
going to pay for bypass surgery now I I
don't know representative
Leon um thank you I'm just trying to
find the
um see where it is so we were we were
discussing something similar to this
earlier today on House Bill
1568 where we were talking about adding
more coverage to Medicaid um and I was
corrected that it's not Commerce it is
Health and Human Services so we are the
body we are the ones who decide how
State revenues are used in the Medicaid
Program and which services to provide so
so um I mean honestly maybe at some
point the Health and Human Services
committee if that becomes a bigger thing
can act like Commerce and have
subcommittees that are dedicated to
medicate coverage and then we can get
that expertise but this seems to be
consistent with what's happening in the
market and perhaps having that
consistency is the least discriminatory
chapero um several weeks ago regarding a
different bill I had the um opportunity
to speak to Rob Barry who is the um
attorney for Medicaid for Department of
Health and Human Services I was actually
asking about coverage for other things
like
cosmetic breast reductions and um breast
augmentation and he made it clear that
those things Wen uncovered and what he
said to me is Medicaid only covers
medically necessary
procedures that is already that is
already the case and the fact is is that
they consider this a medically necessary
procedure so I don't know why we're
taking this one issue and
interceding on behalf of
um this one particular issue and one
particular advocacy group that has
strong feelings about this one
particular issue I think the policy of
Medicaid New Hampshire Medicaid is
already that it's only covers medically
necessary procedures
think we starting to go on in circles a
little bit here repeat ourselves unless
somebody has up something new why don't
we go to the
vote any anything new I'm not saying it
all right so the motion is a to pass as
amended on House Bill 1683 FN ask
collect call the r representative Leon
yes representative bone
yes represent Bill King yes represent
copal yes
representative Lui
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelosa
yes representative Canon
yes representative
Thomas
yes representative M
no representative fedus yes
representative nut upam
no representative Shapiro
yes representative Harriet cther
no representative Palmer
no Representative taes no representative
McDonald
yes
146 I assume there'll be a Minority
Report who's writing The Minority Report
on
that representative
Shapiro okay that is the last bill for
today uh we let me just go down through
the list so everybody knows what they're
doing and uh is Christina Dyer still
over there or she's not so anyway uh
yeah we're gonna miss the calendar for
this uh the deadline for today so if you
could get it to me by the end of the
week is that reasonable
um don't tell the speaker I told you
that uh hopefully he's hopefully well
hopefully he's not he can't watch every
minute so let me let me just go through
what I have um HB 1585 was continued to
March
20th um HB
1712 uh Nel Dave Nagel you're running
you're writing that you're doing the
report on
1712 oh I okay I haven't checked my
email uh that was gone consent so
there's only one report HB 1010
representative Missour okay HB 1638 FN
uh I'm doing that one I have not done it
yet uh HB 1663 representative Lon yes HB
1300 was continued to the
20th HB 1028 representative Shapiro
you're doing that one okay uh HB 1280 uh
that was
continued HB 1347 there's a majority
report represent
kofalt okay thank you and representative
Shapiro you doing a Minority Report on
that
it well no I'd like it this week yeah
I'd like it definitely this week whole
half a week uh two days
actually um HB 1568 was continued to the
20th hb67 was continu continue to the
20th HB 1615 representative copal okay
thank you and HB 1683 representative
Leon you're doing the major uh majority
representative Shapiro you're doing the
minority on that so that sound right to
everybody all right I know of no other
business unless somebody else has
something else to say representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair I just want
to be sure I have um those who have a
desire to look at
uh
1367 you please send me an email I'll
see if I can set up some time to talk
about those bills be an ad Haw meeting
this is not going to be formal it's just
going to be us working offline okay
thank you anything else no
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman uh my thought would be that if
we haven't heard back from the clerk and
speaker but um we'll probably my guess
would be we'd try and figure figure out
how to fit it in within our normal uh
yes we need to have a hearing on the
amendment so shall we look to do that
next Wednesday um maybe 10 o' or or
after lunch if um depending on what the
schedule
afterwards right we were hoping we I
wouldn't want to come in just with the
one bill yeah please so I I know I guess
the question is um since we're not just
doing it as a okay then um I guess so
we'll have we'll have six bills to exec
plus that hearing right yes um so then
the question would be how the thing is
with six bills to exact with that being
a deadline those reports have to be in
that day because the deadline is the
21st so so they have to be done that
day uh 9:30 not usually 9:30 works for
everyone or do we start at 9: with the
hearing on that we can do 9 that's even
better executive session starting at 9
again everybody wouldn't have to be here
at 9: for the hearing that
works why don't we why don't we start at
9ine on the 20th then okay um
representative Shapiro is someone going
to write the amendment or have the
amendment written prior to the hearing
which the well it's actually on the
amendment that's already done right so
um we can do it on the here Amendment
that's already done if we were to add
any Ru making or the injectables um
those would still be gerine to what we
have now so but but since we're doing it
the same day it seems like someone
should have that Amendment written
definitely seems that way that would be
helpful if there's anything you wanted
to write or that representative be no
continu volunteering I'm just saying
you're volun told there will be no
continues that day because they have to
be done that talking about that needs to
have something written anything else
sorry representative TZ my question was
which which Bill are we talking about
day yes the one that we had that large
amendment that um the speaker has ruled
um that it's non remain so we should we
need to have a non gerain hearing um
we've already discussed most of those
issues so as long as there's nothing
that comes up and makes us realize that
this is a big problem I don't see a
problem with us doing it on the 20th
then um and then if we realize that
we're we've we've uh drifted into a m
field then we adapt with that Madam Vice
chair yes can we maybe only schedule 15
minutes for that that day instead of 30
that way we can start on the executive
session at like 9:15 instead of having
to wait just in case we probably could
but we probably wouldn't be scheduling
the executive session until 9:30 anyways
so if we started at 9: so that we can do
that um that way if it is a little bit
longer um I'd be uncomfortable starting
okay just just one note when I wrote
most of anything else yeah when I wrote
most of the education blur we used to
call them years ago I had them all
written before the hearing before the
exec session
our executive sessions can be very
noted anything else if not we stand
no